so one of the jurors
in the derek chauvin trial gave an
interview yesterday morning
in the interview she said i was worried
that everybody would be mad or you know
no matter what the verdict was
and i said this as close as we're going
to get to an admission that the riots
played a role
later in the afternoon another interview
came out where she was straight up like
i didn't want to go through riots and
destruction again and i was scared
someone would come to my house in
retaliation and i'm like wait a minute
that's dramatically different that's an
outright statement because yes you know
trump supporters going around burning
things down over the chauvin verdict
we know what she was scared of and so
this is i got to say this is going to be
their appeal
they go to a judge they say look here's
the here's what the jurors were thinking
they should have sequestered the jury
they should have moved venue we're going
to talk about this we got a bunch of
other stories we're talking about a lot
of
woke wokeness in movies and uh we're
gonna we're gonna do it we're gonna talk
about the falcon and winter soldier
again
because i just watched the finale and it
is not woke it is pro-america and i
thought it was great
it's strangely pro-nationalist and
anti-antifa
it's just so weird to see people ragging
on it and thinking it's far left or
whatever but we'll talk about it because
it's deliciously centrist
now i could do all that work i'm taking
that off because we got someone here who
can handle it for me we got michael
knowles so thanks for having me it's
great to be
here you know i i think i saw like one
and a half
of marvel movies once so i think i'm an
expert i can pontificate
on the whole universe and i haven't seen
the movies you're talking about but
i'll just talk about it it's fine it's
never stopped me before that's that's
that's i think that's uh indicative of
the cable news
you know class so you should be fine but
that's great you'll get a job at cnn no
problem
they'll be like i like what this guy
does he doesn't do any research in the
talks it's perfect for cnn
that's like me it's like ian what marvel
movies did you see marvel movie and a
half
so i saw i had to go see the end game
movie
my friends dragged me to that i saw it i
didn't like it but i saw it
and i i saw part of one of the captain
americas
and it was actually pretty good i don't
i'd actually it was the
the winter one soldier winter soldier i
said that one was okay
but generally speaking there were a few
superhero movies i like i liked uh dark
knight
i liked logan but the thing is though
they're not really superhero movies
right those those are kind of the
exceptions logan's just a western
basically
yeah so i yeah i'm not like i was
thinking
i'm not like a real cool guy you know
like i don't i don't see all the cool
marvel movies i don't wear a beanie i
was thinking i was gonna wear a beanie
here today you should
do you so the problem all right i'll
just show it this is not gonna look good
my head was not was not built for a
beanie so when i
put it over your headphones yeah i wanna
don't my head it's a macabini it looks
uh i know i love
that i mean it's jameis's fault i could
turn it into like a
uh like a headband like an 80s headband
but otherwise otherwise my head just
looks like a peanut
so that's it i can't be a cool guy and
i've accepted my lot in life
all right i feel like i derailed what
you were gonna say you're not a cool guy
but something cool or uh education no
that was it
that was all of it that was the whole
point yeah well thanks thanks thanks for
having me
there's the in and then there's me in
the corner pushing buttons it's gonna be
a really fun show i'm excited for our
cultural commentator here
this should be great so before we get
started go over to timcast.com become a
member and ask
access to exclusive members only
segments you just go to the website you
click members only it should be very
easy and then you see this thing over
here it's like hey look at that you can
become a member
we're working on making the site getting
new payment options and everything but
the time being so you know here's how
you do it you then
go over to click members area and you'll
see we got a bunch of really awesome
segments i've been shouting out the
segment we did
with charlie leduff because you know
charlie was this really funny guy he's a
great guest he's very smart he's got a
ton of integrity everybody was like
super stoked to see him on he's this
amazing reporter
and then we do this bonus segment with
him and all of a sudden he gets like
real somber and he's like let me tell
you some of these stories about you know
being on the ground during 9 11.
man he told me some stuff that sent
chills down my spine of what some of
these these
these journalists and reporters do no
joke so go take me to come check out
check out stuff and uh i i think
we'll uh you'll you're around for uh for
a bonus segment yeah we could do it i'll
be around all night i've got
nothing else nothing else i got a drink
and a cigar waiting for me at the hotel
otherwise
yours nice well let's talk about this uh
let this story i'm sure many people are
probably
familiar with this because this actually
came out yesterday afternoon but i
thought it was uh
important enough to kick off the
conversation and i'll just say i mean
we were already having a pretty crazy
philosophical conversation before things
got started but let's talk about you
know black lives matter these riots
for those that haven't seen the news we
have this from k-a-r-e-11
quote i wish it didn't have to happen
alternate jarrah reflects on derek
chovin trial
now the first and most important thing
is she didn't know she was an alternate
she was in the trial the same as
everyone else treating exactly the same
as any other juror
it was only once they announced
deliberations he said
juror 96 and you're you know so and so
you're you are our alternates you can go
and that's when she's like okay so her
mentality
i believe is indicative of the the views
of many of the other jurors
however to be fair this is the juror who
lived in brooklyn center where the dante
wright riots were happening
she literally had to drive through the
riots on the way to court
we have this uh so this is an interview
and we have this uh
let me let me just let me just read
regoose the
the journalist says quote did you want
to be a juror and the juror says
i had mixed feelings there was a
question on the question there was a
question on the questionnaire about it
and i put i did not know the reason
at the time was i did not know what the
outcome was going to be
so i felt like either way you're going
to disappoint one group or the other
i did not want to go through rioting and
destruction again and i was concerned
about people coming to my house if they
were not happy with the verdict
do you think this lady reasonably feared
trump supporters or conservatives
rioting and showing up at their house i
think she feared insurrectionists
and i know that we're supposed to
believe that trump supporters are the
insurrectionists but
we did see an insurrection last year we
saw it go on for months
we saw it go on not just in one city or
two cities it went on around the country
didn't just target government buildings
it targeted private businesses and
private citizens resulted in deaths
arson
terrorism what else do you call it
terrorism is when you target civilians
to achieve a political end
and look i get why she feared it i mean
there was a babylon bee headline
right before the verdict came out it
said the jurors read their last will
and testimony because of course and
so should this have led to a mistrial
right that was the big question
yep maxine waters calls for riots joe
biden later on
i'm sorry i'm sorry i've interrupted
maxine waters incited insurrection
carrie yes i'm sorry incited and
insurrection
joe biden the same thing he put his
thumb on the scales for the for the jury
and ultimately they go to convict him
because
they wouldn't rule a mistrial you
remember the judge said well hey
this is bad you know i wish waters
didn't do that
but anyway it's okay they're probably
not reading the news so we're not gonna
have a mistrial
but i bet you got something on appeal so
what do you say when he says i bet you
got something on appeal he's saying
i should declare a mistrial but i'm too
cowardly because i don't want them to
burn down my house
and so here's my my only point on it is
okay this juror comes out and says yeah
i was terrified of the mob
killing me and burning down my city um
why is the the judge on the appeal gonna
feel any differently than the judge
during the trial gonna feel any
differently than the jurors
everyone's afraid of this terrorist
left-wing mob because
they not only are making the threats
they're credible threats
because they already did it and they
already got away with it
it's terrorism and the funny thing is
they're bragging about it on twitter
yeah there's a meme right now so i
tweeted uh what did i
tweeted something like i said like holy
s you know and a quote from the lady
saying i don't want to go through the
rights
and some left is supposed to meme where
it's you know the the guy sweating and
the two buttons yeah
and it said violence doesn't solve
anything the riots caused the show
inverted i'm like you're celebr
you're encouraging the right to get
violent like i'm trying to tell people
not to get violent because
you don't want violence and here you
have the left gloating and bragging that
they engaged in acts of terrorism
yeah outside successfully what's scary
though is
i guess for one i don't really think
it's a conservative
and liberal thing i think the issue is i
often describe it as politically
initiated and uninitiated
so why is it that you know i'm a fairly
moderate kind of you know left-leaning
libertarian type and we're laughing and
agreeing
it's because we both know that no true
facts
yeah there's probably some things we
disagree on in terms of what we think
may be real
but as individuals who are discerning of
the news and seeking out the truth
we both know certain facts yeah the
riots exist
they terrify people it's for a political
goal we might disagree on policy
but we agree on what's happening in this
country but most of these liberals and
these people who are voting for
democrats have no idea
they don't pay attention so in their
defense by the way
tim let's just take that story that
happened
what two days ago in columbus where the
cops shot the girl who was stabbing the
other girl
about to stab i'm sorry yeah it was it
was just all well and good that kind of
you know you're a kid
you there's no way to know if she was
really gonna you don't know there's a
little innocent shanking between friends
and so if you were
just a regular american right a regular
kind of liberal american you don't watch
your show you don't watch my show
you're you're you know maybe you don't
watch podcasts maybe you
watch network news which is still the
way millions of americans get their news
and you watch nbc and you watch lester
holt's broadcast the nightly news
you would not have seen the knife they
he they edited out the knife
they played the clip the the girl is
about to shank the other girl
they freeze the frame but keep the audio
going so the knife is out of the frame
and all you hear is bang bang bang bang
the girl goes down
and then in the news report they say and
the the police officers say she was
holding a knife a knife was later found
on the ground no
they show a picture of the knife on the
ground on the ground yeah on the ground
so it's not not their fault that they're
being lied to
so i i think i talked about last week
there was a clip from mike.com
all right i'm at a trump rally in
janesville wisconsin this is back in
like 2015 or 2016.
this young woman was arguing with it
with an older man and everyone's
raucous and in a crowd and she's yelling
he touched my breast he touched my
breast and the old guy had his hands up
saying i did not touch you i didn't
touch you
she punches him in the face and then
someone else pepper sprays her
mike.com added a flare
as if they were doing an edit because it
was the weirdest thing ever
she goes he touched my breast he touched
my breast and then the screen flashes
white
to cover up the punch and then it shows
her getting pepper sprayed
and the story they run is woman sexual
you know teenager is sexually assaulted
and then pepper sprayed by trump
supporters
and i'm like yeah man that's the news we
get
and the problem is you know my pal
andrew clavin makes this point a lot
when we read the news or we watch a news
story about something that we know about
we we can look at it and say hm yeah
that doesn't sound right to me
uh no i actually know that's not true
now i actually have my own lion eyes
here you know and i knew that that was
not true
but then when we get to another story
where we don't i don't know iran or
something right so i'm not an expert on
we just take their word for it the thing
we know about we know they're lying to
us but then the rest
who knows that's the gel man amnesia
effect yes have you heard the
that's so there's a guy who said he was
gonna name it after two smart people so
it sounds official
so i don't know i i don't know i
remember who actually coined the phrase
but man it's it it rings true iran is a
really great example when i see cnn say
something like
you know hezbollah has done this i just
go like i guess
yeah maybe and then i watch them talk
about the riots like peaceful protesters
burn down the city and i'm like
it must have been peaceful yeah am i yes
is hezbollah good
i don't know i don't know i don't i
don't think that's the case but who
knows what they're lying about you know
right yeah and so
especially when it comes to foreign
policy yeah we get into wars because of
it because the american people are just
i guess i just trust it and so that
that's kind of why
i i think the easiest example of this is
true
the real political divide or one i
shouldn't say the real but this one of
the strongest
is do you actually pay attention to the
world worldly affairs because
you and i will disagree on politics but
we agree on what's happening with the
world which allows us to
you know applying a standard american
moral framework come to similar
conclusions on what should or shouldn't
be
yeah and there's also if you really want
to get woke to the political scene
one has to recognize there is a
difference between how the government is
supposed to work and how the government
works on paper
and how the government actually works
and the kind of real
ruling establishment and actually the
right wing is finally waking up to this
a little bit
when you know for 20 years the right
wing talked about how
there's the you know the public and the
private and the government and business
and you know public government bad
private business good and yeah maybe
this woke multinational corporation is
undermining our entire country and
culture but
but they're good they're good company
give money to company give tax cut to
company and government
even though the government is an
expression of our own political wills
through
through our elected representatives we
hope when it's working bad right
but now what is google is
google's a private company no we were by
squishy republicans we were told
google's a private company for a long
time
that doesn't seem that private to me
when when three billionaire oligarchs
control the flow of information in a
republic where speech is politics right
it's the same thing
the way we govern ourselves is we
persuade one another of things if three
companies are controlling that
that practically speaking is the
government you know i go back and forth
on this sometimes depending on the news
depending on you know how it's it's hard
to gauge
whether we are winning or losing and by
we i mean the people who believe in
individual rights free expression
and uh i guess i think we're classified
classically
i don't want to bring down everything
here by design well you know what so
you know there was a funny comment
earlier someone in the chat said they
saw michael in the title and they were
hoping for malice but they got nulls
instead
real nice they're like okay real nice
guys
but but you know michael mouse of the
opinion that we're winning yeah
that uh and there's there's good reasons
to think so
like youtube just relaxed its rules on
uh community guidelines and monetization
some of them give people pause like
you're now allowed to show police
brutality videos and monetize
them which is you know they think that's
actually the other direction
it popularizes the myth of police going
on hunting microwaves and things like
that
right but they also have now opened it
up to
you know more adult themed content to
put it mildly like news coverage very
serious you know issues swearing even
and so maybe that's a move in the right
direction i wonder though
if some of the relaxation is just
because
the election passed this is why the
election's over they're always really
nice to us
when it doesn't matter you know but when
it really does matter
they i mean i think we actually did see
them cross the rubicon
during the shortly after the election
during the litigation
where some hipster rasputin this guy
with the nose ring in silicon valley
deplatformed the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
regardless of what you think happened in
the election the guy's the president and
this
oligarch took him out and he could take
him out and it wasn't just him
they all worked in concert with one
another and i i
sort of i mean this is actually a lot of
the topic of my my book my
second book but my first book with words
which is called speechless and
it's it's about this this problem of
free speech what is it you know i think
it gets back to your point tim which is
so right the reason that i think we keep
losing ground
we lose grounded maybe they pat us on
the head and they're nice to us when it
doesn't matter but
we still keep losing is because we
are only thinking about ourselves we're
only thinking about this
individualist hyper-individualist
ideology we're only thinking about the
debate as one between
free speech and censorship when i don't
think it's i think it's a debate between
competing sets of standards
and it actually leads us into a trap
this i think conservatives fall for this
trap i think
the left understands free speech way
better than conservatives do
i think we kid ourselves when we pretend
that we understand it better
and the trap is this political
correctness
tries to destroy the old order that's
all it wants to do once to all the old
rituals all the ultra it wants to get
rid of it
and conservatives react one of two ways
either this we go along with it that's
what the squishes do and they say oh who
cares
oh the squid it's not a big deal
actually drag queen story hour is a
blessing of liberty
yeah whatever you know it's that kind of
thing and then but the second
way we respond which i think we we've
probably all fallen into this camp at
various times myself certainly included
is we'll say okay no i'm not going along
because i'm a free speech absolutist i'm
a
free expression whatever absolutist and
so
no one can ever tell me that this is
better than that or this is more true
than that
i'm going to be able to do whatever i
want and so you
disavow standards altogether either way
either way the radical leftists get what
they want i think
i am one of the worst possible things
for conservatives
in the long run in that and i've i've
maintained this
for years they like so when i first
started
doing youtube yeah the people at google
that i was working with were like their
liberal
you know liaisons and stuff and i know a
lot of people at google yeah
and then eventually they started calling
me a centrist i was i was
you know and they say you know you're
changing and i'm like my videos from
2014 are of the same opinion i did a
video in 2014 about you know a
segregated graduation ceremony that was
wrong i think we should segregate
yeah my opinions are relatively the same
in fact i've become more liberty minded
and actually i take the political
compass test i'll actually move further
to the left ideologically
but they keep calling me they first say
tim's oh tim's a liberal
he's not a progressive then they say
he's a centrist yeah now they're calling
me right wing you're a fascist
so well they've never they don't call me
fascist right that's why i say i'm one
of the worst things for conservatives
i think the reason why youtube likes
what i do
and i have a good go of things when they
ban conservatives
they want to make sure that
conservatives stay on platform
and so there has to be something that's
semi-acceptable to some conservatives
there are a lot of people who are
conservatives who like i disagree with
tim but you know watch his show
yeah well what happens when they get rid
of crowder right then the people who are
on who are on youtube
who remain will be like i'll still watch
tim but then they're going to get a more
liberal viewpoint
that's rotating the wheel and spinning
and pushing the overton wind to the left
i don't literally think i'm the worst
thing for conservatives i think we do
good work here to try and be fair to
everybody
but they're trying to rotate the wheel
so that centrist becomes far right
and actual liberals become conservative
and then that is
so perceptive i mean because basically
what what you're seeing happening in
real time is what reagan said
i didn't leave my party my party left me
you're seeing that happen to you but
you're also
you're self-aware enough to realize
they're doing it with you you you
actually are the evidence of that
overton window shifting
and and well that's the point though is
the overton window right which is
i think that sometimes conservatives and
i've been guilty of this myself
years past we pretend
that there is a thing total absolute 100
free speech
that's the american way isn't it no it
never has been it never will be there
have always been broad swaths of speech
in america that you're not allowed to
say
sedition fraud fighting words
why and why obscenity actually is a
really big one garland
george seven words can't say on tv seven
words you can't say on tv now you have
to say those words
but why were you not allowed to say
those things because all of those things
fraud
obscenity are speech that undermines
speech
at least in the understanding of the
founding fathers and i think
of the smartest people on this issue for
all time
in the 1950s you'd get canceled for
being a communist today
you will get cancelled for not being a
communist
there's always going to be some kind of
cancelling they're always going to be
things you can't say and you can't do
but look at how that has shifted look at
the way that
in in the 1950s if you burned an
american flag you might be taken up on
the smith act
what was the smith act smith act was an
anti-communist right
but you know we've had these sorts of
bills going back to the founding not not
particularly with communism but with all
sorts of subversive ideologies
today if you you could go out you could
burn a flag in the streets
and the left has gotten the
conservatives to defend them
to celebrate that nothing more american
than burning the american flag
that's a big cultural victory for the
left but you know here's the thing
i've always been a liberal and i think
people have a right to free speech so
long as their own property they can burn
it
now like i said they're trying to call
me a conservative you're right the
people on twitter are like tim's are
right winger you right-wingers
now the funny thing is i got called left
by a right-wing outlet and right by a
left-wing outlet and so i just like
screenshot it and put it on twitter and
i'm like i have found the singularity
like
people don't realize centrism exists and
they think centrism is like agreeing
with the worst parts of like
you know the left and right no it's like
agreeing that some people on the right
have it right some people have some good
points
there's something very conservative by
the way about centrism i i don't mean
i'm i'm slightly to the right of genghis
khan
but there's something really something
really berkey in something really
conservative about centrism
it's it's actually what i i tried to do
this this was kind of the
beginning idea for my book is i
wanted to take the left-wing
intellectuals seriously
because you know we do this all the time
on the right we say oh you know the
critical theorists there i hate them or
marx or you know gramsci
or whoever whoever it is marcus right
but no one actually engages with them
and
the thing about those guys those radical
left theorists
is they're super duper intelligent which
is why
they've been so successful and we keep
losing
you know i love quoting marks when i can
to like prove
points about like liberty for instance
yeah to be honest there's only one i can
actually
reference and it's under no pretext
shall arms and ammunition be surrendered
the working class should uh should um
frustrate this
by force if necessary and so i tweeted
under no pretext shall the right to keep
and bear arms be infringed with a
picture of an m16
on a trans flag because i'm like
freedom liberty and guns there is no if
marx were alive today he would be on the
alt-right there's no question about it
he would i'm serious i'm not even sure i
mean there's right he's going to be like
a biden
liberal establishment neolib i don't
think so no he was racist
yeah and uh and yeah he was yeah
it's funny he really and he really
didn't like the jews even though he was
you know he's
he's he's a racist anti-semite who
believed in owning guns
it's closer to alt right than you're
going to get anybody on the left
actually you know we were talking about
sheamus from freedom
because he was just here but he has a
very very popular cartoon you may have
seen
where the woke left desperate to stop
the nazis
use a time machine to bring world war ii
soldiers to the future yeah
and then when they try explaining to
them what's happening the soldiers
so they're like you know our president
is a fascist
and then they give him a brochure and
then the world war two soldiers go
oh my what your president supports gay
marriage
it's like the world war ii soldiers were
ridiculously conservative yeah
well certainly by the i mean by the
standards of today like will and grace
was ridiculously conservative
because because hemingway describes this
in the sun also rises he's talking about
how you go bankrupt
so how's you go how'd you go bankrupt
and the guy says gradually
then suddenly and that you know we've
kind of gone through this gradually
period
which is i don't know 60s 70s 80s
it seems to me like we are very much in
the suddenly phase
i mean just think about we went from
barack obama and hillary clinton saying
marriage is a sacred bond between a man
and a woman
to if you don't castrate your child
you're a bigot
come on trans the kids bigot we did that
in like six years or something
this is this is where i think an
interesting thing happens
you're substantially more conservative
than i am but i
as a you know as a traditional american
liberal over the past couple decades
have a red line on what i think doesn't
doesn't make sense so i was a big fan of
tulsi gabbard
yeah and what did tulsi gabbard say she
said safe legal but rare when it came to
abortion right
and so that was where the the liberals
were 10 years before
so something happened and i think it has
a lot to do with social media
where well it's a combination of things
but do you think social media played a
huge role in the rapid
left design leftization or whatever you
want to call it of the establishment
to where like some i i
i i voted for obama the first time
because of the war issue i didn't want
to
vote for him the second time i
considered myself to be you know younger
anarchy leftists got older kind of
learned some some things then was like
i'm a liberal
then i got older and i was like actually
i should open my mind and listen to you
know people of all different backgrounds
and i see these things happening with
like uh it was i think michelle wolf is
her name the comedian yeah
where she goes on her netflix show and
she goes you get an abortion and you can
and i was like that scares me
yeah because like the argument that i
understood growing up from a very
liberal family was
safe legal rare yeah like it was it was
supposed to be like a medical thing
where your doctor is here to help you
you know why it changed and i actually
have sympathy for the left on this as to
why it changed
because everybody recognized that you
know it's
abortion is not a thing you want you
don't want more of it right i mean
everybody even if you you support
legal abortion you don't you don't like
go celebrate it
but they do now and it's because the
legal and rare issue
raised this question of what is an
abortion if it has any moral similarity
to murder then it shouldn't be legal
if it if it isn't morally similar to
murder then there's no reason for it to
be rare
and i i think they couldn't stand the
kind of
gnawing shame of that and and there's a
lot of different places the shame could
come from
and they couldn't it had to be never
with the left
do they merely want you to tolerate them
never do they merely want you to accept
them you must
affirm them you must validate every
single
desire that they want and so very
quickly on a whole host of issues not
just abortion
you go from hey i have this disordered
desire please just
tolerate it two if you don't take your
kids
to watch me do this thing and you don't
put it on nickelodeon shows
then you're a bigot and there's no true
equity in the world there was the the
dead in canada who got arrested for not
using the proper pronouns
for his child child
yeah that's the safe way to say it well
no because i don't know i don't know
what the
the actual gender of the child is
because depending on which source you
read
they'll say something different so you
know you you'll read the new york times
and it'll say the man's daughter
and then you'll read say the daily wire
i'll say the man's son yeah and so i'm
just like
but you see that this is trust you know
what i mean that issue to me is why it
all
is so important the thing that drives me
craziest are these conservatives who
they're
they're in that ladder group of people
with pc where they say oh come on you
know
i'll you do you i'm not gonna it doesn't
affect me do whatever you want just
don't raise my taxes or whatever
it does if there are very few people who
are men who think that they're women or
vice versa very very few people it's a
social contagion
also beyond the psychological issue so
it is growing especially among younger
people but
taking that aside it's still a small
number of people
if if i can't
know if i can't make a claim about
objective reality that you will respect
and you can't make a claim about
objective reality that i will respect
in something as fundamental as the most
basic distinction of human nature
who's a boy and who's a girl then we
can't communicate
right right what is language it's just
it's symbols that we use to
refer to objective reality and try to
shape the kind of world that we want to
live in and recognize reality if we
if yeah if we cannot
do that there is no self-government
there is no logic to this place it's
just
warring bands of interests the
interesting thing about when it comes to
and this is a really obviously dangerous
subject for youtube especially yeah you
know it's like
walking on ice because they're ready to
just hit the nuke button yeah but i was
reading something about
um i can't remember what it was it was a
year or so ago about
a world world-class athlete who had won
some competitions the individual used he
him pronouns but was
biologically female it completely
altered the context
of everything because
in in certain sporting events i can tell
you who the world class top athletes are
yeah there's probably the names of
there's probably several names in say
the wnba you've probably never heard of
probably more than several yeah right
well then yeah
i don't know if it was you tweeted that
joke and i tweeted the uh the family guy
clip
maybe it wasn't you wasn't you i did see
the clown i forget if i tweeted it or
not yeah yeah
anyway if you have we'll use the wnba
as an example lebron james particularly
woke in many ways
and pro-ccp and we all know he's like
the cream of the crop the best of the
best
they say he commands you know hundreds
of millions of dollars a year
let's say you have uh and again i'm
saying this with the utmost respect i'm
trying to explain a concept of
linguistics and understanding of reality
let's say you have a wnba player
yeah who is called the top of her league
the best of the best
commanding the highest salary in the
league and then the person comes out as
trans
so in the encyclopedia of the pedia they
change all the pronouns
from she to he and him now it says he
commands the highest salary in the
league
he won all of the greatest championships
and it really changes the context
because it not sounds like they're
actually above lebron james right
so i need to be able to understand the
context and these things
matter well it it matters
to the very essence of the society i
mean you you know you you love
philosophy and so this there's this very
shallow idea that you know you keep your
religion out of my politics you
look man that's to quote the dude man
that's just your opinion man you know so
don't
just let we're just going to talk about
taxes or whatever no all
all laws legislate morality all human
conflict ultimately is theological
you know there's the breitbart doctrine
which is politics is downstream of
culture culture is downstream of
religion cult and culture they come from
the same root word ultimately we're
talking about
first principles who we are the
traditional understanding for our whole
civilization everywhere
everywhere in the world certainly in
this country is that we are
you know body and soul and yes i'll i'll
move
i'll bring you back to one more root and
that's religion is
it comes after moral frameworks yeah
well yeah exactly no this is actually a
perfect way
to put it as moral frameworks
if if i'm going to explain human nature
to in the old way i say i'm body and
soul right
and for the purposes of a lot of public
policy i might just be body but but not
for all public policy you know why is
why is sexual assault worse than any
other kind of assault
because we're more than just our bodies
right there's there's a kind of human
dignity that's being violated here okay
fine
that's the the to use the technical term
the hylomorphic view of human nature
there's the materialist view which is
just for meat puppets and then there's
the transgender view which is
an ancient heresy it's called gnostic
dualism it's the idea that
my true self has nothing to do with my
body so i might look like a dude i got a
deep voice i got the adam's apple
various other appendages but if on some
deep
metaphysical level i feel myself to be a
woman
not only is it sort of complicated you
know and i'm a little bit i'm i'm just a
woman
because my myself my actual self has
nothing to do with my body
you can't live in a society that
simultaneously holds these
contradict reviews of what human nature
is you've got to decide
i i you have you seen the the the jack
dorsey thing i did with joe rogan yeah
it was just
absolutely magnificent i appreciate it
yes
uh it comes up a lot but i think there
was like a very important point
that uh i brought up to jack or to
vijaya and it's that
when i said your rules are inherently
biased against conservatives
they didn't understand this yeah and
then i said conservatives view the
phrase misgendering differently from the
way you view it
right and you can argue that you're in
the majority
they can argue they're the majority how
do you rectify that bias
you have if half the country votes for
donald trump and the other half doesn't
you can it's fair to say that half the
voting body that are active in politics
believe that misgendering someone means
to use pronouns that don't align with
their biological
sex yeah the so that's the essentialist
view then the constructivist view would
be
the other way around that misgendering
is when you don't use the pronouns that
adhere to their
self-identification yeah we right now
have an infrastructure that's being
built upon
you as a conservative your world view is
considered wrong a moral or
or a fringe even though i think when you
look at the data it's actually the
majority of individuals would
certainly which why go back to the
politically uninitiated versus initiated
yeah
my thing comes down to probably like
more libertarianism
in the small sense not the libertarian
party because they get kind of kooky
in that if someone comes to me and says
here's what i'd like to be called i say
no problemo yeah absolutely and
i don't think that twitter's argument
for why
they ban people who violence policy is
sufficient
i don't think youtube's is and i think
it's causing serious damage as you
probably agree to
discourse and politics there the
argument was that there's a high rate of
suicide among trans people therefore
yeah
and my argument uh it's not even i'm
arguing against
the right of individuals to be respected
you know i i don't think everyone has a
right to just have respect but i do
think society
my personal opinion is we try to give
people the benefit of the doubt towards
respecting them until they prove
otherwise but it does raise this
question
which is and and this is actually just
as dangerous for society
what is the respect it seems to me what
the conservatives are saying is
if i see a man who wants to be called a
woman uh
and you call him a man you're showing
him respect because you are you're not
treating him like a crazy person you're
treating him like someone
who can understand reality and you're
just saying look this is
this is how i see it pal it kind of
looks like you're a man and if you lie
to him
then you're being very disrespectful you
don't lie to people that you have
respect for
but i think on the left the argument
they're making is lies
in this case even if we're all we're
gonna all admit you know he's not really
a girl but
it's nice because it's socially
constructed we should all do it
lies are compassionate and the truth is
cruel
and you know that's not a great premise
for a society
to begin with and it's one that i would
certainly reject it i think i think at
the very least it's exactly
you know everything you online outlined
the conservative view
on why you're actually being respectful
it's exactly the problem with the rules
these social media companies have
yeah in that they you know what i said
what i said to them was you guys think
you're like regular people but
you're not you're billionaire silicon
valley elites who are out of touch with
this country
masters of the universe i'm not saying
you're that you represent
a tiny fringe faction or anything like
that there's a lot of people who agree
with you
yeah but you don't understand that you
have not spoken with a trump supporter
or a conservative
to understand that half the country
disagrees with you and
probably more but you've made rules so
what ends up happening is
the more we use these digital spaces the
more we're filtering our worldview
through theirs
yeah and it's your point about losing
that's probably it
it is because we're i think
what twitter is saying i mean you you
absolutely wrecked them and
and they're being so hypocritical and
they're being so disingenuous a lot of
the time
but the fact remains there are going to
be rules
always have been always will be to every
speech regime
there have to be there just have to be
rules to speech in the sense that
if he is really he then he isn't she and
if he is
is she then he's really not he and one
of us is right and one of us is wrong
but we will have if we're going to have
any kind of society we're going to have
to agree on those rules
and what is being done now is rather
than having them
develop over time out of tradition
through the use of our reason
by applying reason to the natural world
and our perceptions
what is being done is a handful of
extremely radical
people whose whose life experience is
very different from all of ours
are upending society right from that
from under our feet
and there's nothing we can do about it
because they own the platforms and they
enforce
all the rules and you've got like jack
dorsey who sold twitter
basically he only owns like two or six
percent or something of twitter now and
you've got companies like state street
or um blackrock these giant investment
global investment firms that basically
are running the show
and like you said earlier sedition like
type certain types of speech are illegal
for a reason and there is so free speech
means we're not we've all agreed we're
not going to say certain things
and it's like they've taken on this role
of arbiter that they want to
decide for us that we can't say certain
things because
it's dangerous that it will prevent
actual free speech
but i don't think that that's for
corporations to decide personally
not not historically in our country but
that is what's happening now and it's
it's why i think the reason
conservatives lose is because the left
makes a procedural argument
and they make a substantive argument and
what i mean by that is
the left has a view of what free speech
is in the abstract and then they're
going to enforce
certain speech rules the right has this
kind of a historical now we've adopted
over the last 20 years just like total
free speech and there's no limits to
anything
but we won't say what we should say but
free speech has no meaning to people
who have nothing to say freedom of
belief has no meaning to people who
don't believe anything you know you know
what the reason i think it's not just
conservatives who are losing because
obviously to you i'm definitely a
conservative to the right i'm definitely
not a conservative to them
whatever fine but uh we are losing
and whatever that we is it's a
combination of different factions in
politics but
the reason is well i i don't think
you're interested in
lying cheating and stealing right uh i'm
certainly not either yeah i
like enlightenment values i like sitting
down having conversations with people i
believe in
respecting uh so for me when it comes to
you know pronouns or whatever i give the
benefit of doubt towards respect
i like to sit down and have
conversations i don't like to manipulate
people into doing my bidding
yeah however the issue i have with
modern leftism as it stands
as is the authoritarianism of it where
they believe
their the moral framework of of wokeness
is
might makes right yeah are you familiar
with david graber
no i'm not david graber was a very
famous anthropologist
who uh didn't like that he was called
the anarchist anthropologist he was one
of the
most he was one of the influencers who
ignited occupy wall street at these
meetings
and uh he passed recently so you know
rest in peace david graber
he did a twitter thread a few years ago
where he said elements of the left have
been adopting fascistic ideologies
the idea that there's no truth but power
and that mike might makes right
yeah that's my problem with weakness
yeah that they're basically
there's no rules i want to know what the
rules are so i can respect you
yeah but they purposefully have no rules
it's just the imposition
is what matters you know at this point
is so important someone the other day
well this happens every day but the
other day i
responded someone called me a fascist
and i pointed out i said
i am way too reactionary to be a fascist
and that is like small potatoes and what
i mean by that is
to your point exactly fascism is
an atheistic status philosophy that
basically just worships
the the exercise of state power that
doesn't work with my world view because
i think that there are some things that
are
true i think there are eternal truths
there's an eternal moral order
but this is something that conservatives
don't want to acknowledge when i say
they don't want to say anything what i
mean is this
you get the squishy types who say well
look you know if we tell
drag queen story hour that they can't
twerk for kids at the library
then they might tell us we can't go to
church on sunday and they say like first
of all they're already telling us we
can't go to church on sunday
but but second of all if you cannot
distinguish
between twerking for toddlers and going
to church on sunday
if you can't say one of those is better
than the other one
one of those is better for then you have
lost your
faculties of judgment your moral
conscience which is the prerequisite
for self-government at that point throw
in the towel well i'll i'll i'll put it
uh
in a different way let's say you have
let's say i'm sitting in my
my arbiter's chair and i see a leftist
say we should be allowed to have you
know drag qreen story hour
and then to my right as a conservative
saying we should be able to go church on
sunday
i say to the to to you and your
community on the religious side you
should be allowed to go to church and
your community should function as you
you see moral and fit and this other
group they live in a different society
if you guys want to have and live your
own ways i respect that the problem
though
is one group is telling you what you can
and can't do because they're trying to
impose their will
into your community but in their defense
i am trying to impose my will on theirs
and what i mean by what i mean by that
is this
drag queen story hour involves perverts
twerking for toddlers
okay to put it really bluntly well to
clarify too
there's a specific instance in which
somebody was that's what i'm
yeah i'm not speaking loosely here i'm
saying like an actual a guy who actually
committed these crimes right
because this is so much easier to get
into it this way because it involves
children
if a community you know look they've got
their own customs they've and one of the
customs is
that they abuse children and they twerk
for children and they indoctrinate
children into this crazy
licentious ideology but that's their
custom that's what they want to do
do we not have any right to say uh you
shouldn't do that
depends on if you're coming from uh
it's hard it's it's moral frameworks
it's i certainly have my red lines you
know so i look at what happens in some
of these foreign countries
and they're shocking to me and there's a
point where i'm like
questioning the line of warfare for
instance what china does to
the weaker muslims and the women and i
had a very interesting conversation with
cassandra fairbanks where she said
there's no there's no war no matter what
like every country does something wrong
are we gonna go to war with everybody
yeah it's a very interesting libertarian
argument and i think
i think she's right about that why why
don't i care about say
these other countries in you know in
africa where they do atrocities
their atrocities as well and so it's
it's a real challenge of
where the lines are in in in terms of
like the actual physical boundaries
where we're going to say we will enforce
our morality
well i'm sure i'm sure a line for you
would be like the kid stuff i think this
is true a line for most people
because what do we also we say kids
can't consent you know they don't they
don't
really have mastery of their liberty
that's why we have age of consent laws
because we're not going to let
kids do all these sorts of things the
left is trying to uh catch away at that
right now and i'll clarify too right
there's there's the mainstream media
portrayal of drag queen story hour where
it's just people and chairs with books
yeah and there's the actual videos you
see on twitter where they're twerking
for children
yes and so there's the the argument
that i've seen is that twerking is just
dancing from a different culture
so you you it's just like a waltz you
know from a philosophical point of view
and and from a moral from a moral
framework standpoint
my question is are people who vote for
certain things allowed to live certain
ways if they choose
and at what point does someone's
community get to impose their will in
another community well it depends what
they're voting for
you know at one time i got to meet
scalia a couple times
and when i was a student it was amazing
i have no idea how i stumbled into this
opportunity
and someone asked him it was a question
by the second amendment they asked him
hold on
mr justice because you're saying that
it's this individual right to these guns
but only these guns and not these other
guns
how do you decide and his answer i
thought was deeply conservative and
deeply wise he said
you decide very very carefully and i
think we need to decide these things
very carefully too
one stumbling block i think for a lot of
people on this issue
is the nature of liberty what is liberty
you know if
right now they're saying that the kid
should be able to be castrated if he if
he wants to
because that it's his right that's his
liberty if he wants to do it but
but then we say well kids don't really
have liberty because they're not
educated and the whole point of that
liberal education is you you
master your liberty i think the problem
here is this conflation of liberty
and licentiousness meaning the current
sort of modern lib view of liberty is
that liberty means do whatever you want
whatever your base desire is just do
whatever you want and
the the conservative view of liberty the
view of the founders the view of the
christian view the pre-christian view
even
is that liberty is not the ability to do
whatever you want it's the
right to do what you ought to do and
what i mean by that is this i can bring
it right down to earth
a heroin addict actually is a very
popular debate on libertarian circles
right
should you legalize all the drugs should
the heroin addict be able to do whatever
he wants
according to the modern liberal view of
liberty the heroin addict is the most
free guy in the world
right he can do as long as he's got a
buck in his pocket he can shoot up he's
that's awesome he's pursuing his will
and his free choice
but we all know that that guy's not free
we all know he's a slave
he's a slave to his base passions his
higher will i'm sure is telling him
i wish i could stop doing this i hate
the heroine oh addicts will tell you
this all the time
but his lower appetites because he
hasn't cultivated his higher will
his lower appetites his licentiousness
desiring all of that
my my view of the drug war stuff is it
should be legal
in so far as you have to go to
designated facilities that regulate
and actually wean you off of it so
instead of having someone go in the
gutter
they go in for a legal you know session
or whatever
and they can lim they can regulate and
limit so that they can actually
with the purpose of getting them off the
drug right right yeah yeah that makes
you know we have methadone clinics and
things like that yeah
so but but there are people who look at
say portugal and they think we should
just totally legalize everything
yeah i i am of i am of the legalize
everything with regulation
so it's like or i should say
decriminalize with the goal of
helping people instead of you know
locking them up in prison or whatever
but but even in that view that isn't
that isn't exactly my view of it but
even in that view
you are acknowledging the goal should be
people do less of this stuff absolutely
yeah and i think a lot of people now on
the left they say it's it's kind of like
the abortion thing right it's like no we
got to celebrate it we got to shout it
and that's
and that's that way lies madness you
know it to me that whole thing was crazy
because
you know growing up being uh liberal it
it what it meant to me in my
understanding of the things we argued
for was
respecting individual liberties and
civil liberties and civil rights
now the modern liberal whatever that
means does not do that
yeah it's it's well i mean they can
argue that they are
but it's moved well beyond any point of
being responsible in your community
to protect individuals now it's
literally just
no rules no police but you know where
you want they'll burn down the city in
minneapolis or whatever i can't i've got
to defend the left i mean your point is
totally right
but their argument which they really
pushed in the 1970s the radical
feminists pushed this
is that the personal is the political
there's this great essay it's by that
name
and this woman recounts how the new york
radical women's groups
they would meet up i refer to them as
wine and cheese soirees you know these
sort of housewives
or unmarried women would meet up and but
very often when the
bourgeois housewife and the mother of
two would show up
the woman would go there and she was
happy as a clam walking in
and then during the struggle session
they would raise awareness and the woman
would leave
resentful and irritated and because she
is now aware of her own
oppression and this is called being
liberated and then the women would go
out of there
you know uh i used to do non-profit
fundraising and
these these offices they hire large
groups of people
send us out in the streets to wave at
people with clipboards yeah hey do you
have a minute to talk about the
environment you've probably seen those
people already
one when you come back from your day of
hard fundraising on the street
yeah some people aren't of strong mental
fortitude
and they would do debriefs they would
always have a manager do a debrief with
everyone one at a time and then you you
stopping for debrief then you'd leave
and what they were really doing was a
morality check
if somebody in the office had a bad day
they would walk in
and they would have the squiggly line
over their head like the comics
and everyone else who maybe had a bad
day but wasn't really thinking about it
maybe it was an okay day it was a good
day
yeah they'd all be hanging out after
work the person had a bad day
would stand next to them as they say
like how was your day and they'd be like
it was okay for me and they'll go this
is the worst job ever i hate this job
dude people are so awful
dude i had a guy who did this to me and
then everyone starts sharing the
negativity and it spreads
like like a like a virus yeah so what
would happen is they would do a debrief
where
they would ask people how was your day
how do you feel and if
a tiny percentage of people were like
i'm just so tired these people are so
awful
they'd fire everyone in the office
even there was like there would be like
five people who would remain and those
were like the tough willed
so i worked for these companies i was a
nation's best fundraiser for a variety
of these
nonprofits on the street convincing
people to donate to various charities i
didn't think
those guys ever got anybody to sign up
at all that's very impressive
i i i once got a lady to give me a check
for 700
and then give me her bank account
numbers to do it every single month
so like when you have the gift of gab
when you can talk
yeah i'm in the wrong line of work man
that's great no i think you're in the
right line of work
this stuff was dirty it was it's the
opposite of what we're doing you're
speaking
your your truth you're explaining how
you feel and how you want to you know
your goals towards improving things this
was the opposite this was
tricking people and that's why i ended
up leaving when i realized they were
full of it
yeah to your point though about you know
uh
i guess we're talking about like
negativity spreading and this mentality
sort of yeah new york radical women
personal isn't political yeah they'd
come out feeling all angry yeah you take
a bunch of people
who are happy and excited for their job
and you put them in a room
and you're good but one person gets
negative and then
within a week everyone's performance
dropped dramatically
and do you see do you see what that
company understood is that
the personal is the political so if you
have if you have a company full of
pissed off people then you're gonna
you're gonna have a bad company if
and if you if you have a country to get
back to that earlier example you have a
country full of heroin addicts
it doesn't matter how wonderfully
written your constitution is
and how beautiful your supreme court
building is if you're if your
nation is full of individuals who are
atrophied and sick and
and disordered you're going to have a
bad country that's just
an opioid crisis i mean it's not and
that's a literal yeah
right that's a little bit yeah so uh
it's remarkable how easy it is to spread
anger and negativity and how hard it is
to stop it or spread the positivity what
they call runaway breakdown in science
where one electron in a cloud of plasma
will go
and then all the other ones follow it
rapidly and cause lightning as we know
it that's the formation
and because electrons are such
lightweight they move and they follow
each other very quickly relative to the
protons let's
let's do this let's segue this is a hard
segue but i want to talk about um
one of the articles from the daily wire
about uh wokeness
in movies okay and i i do think it's
relevant because i think what we're
seeing
in commercial industry and in movies and
shows
is this kind of you're in a room with 30
other people and one person's pissed off
yeah it's happened to our country it
sounds like twitter yeah exactly
it is and that the the reason why i
think we're seeing movies and
commercials and marketing
go this direction is one there has been
a liberal bias
in the establishment media for a long
time academia
and that meant i think it's probably you
know following
civil rights because i think everybody
for the most part
today in america objectively believe
civil rights were a good thing
yeah there are obviously racists and but
there's it's true there's probably a
handful of people
dude you and far between uh but no on
the left and the right
right you have left identitarians who uh
you know when i was in um
i think baltimore during the riots they
actually were circulating a discussion
about why the
this is black lives matter saying ending
segregation was bad it was wrong
they genuinely thought so so anyway i
digress because of that everything sort
of flowed in that direction
and if you're in the mainstream media
that's what's acceptable
that's what socially just yeah and so
the only conversations that can happen
are racism is bad or something in that
context
so what happens then is when you create
a twitter or a facebook
and it creates the massive room where
everyone can share their rage and enrage
other people
we end up with industry
commercials movies media government and
every
so you know our culture has become built
upon
this low morale demoralized angry
angry about what you know you were
saying earlier like um
what right do we have to say like i want
you to change like to impose
your will on some other person i think
that you twerking for kids is bad
yeah and i think we do have the right to
say that and of course now that's on
social media
and but sometimes you don't have the
right to say like
i think you should commit this crime
because that's
could be considered i don't know
seditious or something like that but
this this whole like i think you should
fill in the blank has has like taken on
this this runaway breakdown
in social media and now people are
imposing like i think you should call me
a man
yeah but let me to your point about
runaway breakdown
and the thing i was saying about the
bias donald trump can say
we're going to peacefully march to the
capitol to cheer on politicians
insurrection maxine waters says if we
don't get what we want we
we do more we get more confrontational
and they're like that's fine
yeah i'm sorry what did the republicans
offer to do censure maxine webb
it's pathetic we will wag our finger at
her they impeached trump over it
literally impeached him yeah and then
tried to convict him
for saying peacefully cheer on
politicians of course it's it's
absolutely pathetic because
your observation here and actually what
we're seeing in hollywood is
every culture just by definition is
gonna
some things and castigate some things
and we're gonna think some things are
good and some things are bad and some
are right and some are wrong
and that's just the way it works and if
conservatives are unwilling to offer a
substantive vision of that
then we're just gonna get rolled over
you know on this this point here of this
kind of nastiness in the movies
however you know it's hollywood and
social media it's all so nasty
i wonder if too beyond just the
political vision of this
it has something to do with how
exhausted
and decadent we are as a society what i
mean by that is
i went to cuba a few years ago it was
they had direct flights from la for a
little very briefly thanks obama
and i go down to buy some cigars i go to
cuba and i see a variety show
and this thing man i don't know i felt
bad for everybody in that slave island
is a terrible place at the time it
looked like they were going to open up
who knows
doesn't look like great reforms i see a
real ricky ricardo show i mean i'm
talking cuban pete he's the king of the
right it's all very
big very energetic very enthusiastic and
i
thought oh my gosh we haven't had that
kind of entertainment in the united
states
for 50 years at least what is our
entertainment now
it's apathetic it's all ironic it's all
just sort of dressed down and like i'm
not even gonna you know
millennials and zoomers too they they
kind of like talking vocal fry
you know it's kind of they won't even
put breath behind their voice
because we're just so damn tuckered out
we're so excited
there's a very popular memes about
harming yourself on on reddit and
there's
the funny thing is it's created a
derivative set of memes where
these genzirs who make jokes about dying
don't know that older generations don't
know it's a joke yeah seriously
yeah but so i wanted to bring up this
thing about hollywood because
i think this is from the daily wire i
think it shows
uh yeah whatever that is website or
whatever shout out apparently there's a
bunch of links on facebook daily wire
daily wires yeah so no no but i think
most people are not into this
the problem is social media has created
uh it's the foreground and people don't
realize that
it looks really big because it's right
in front of our faces but it's actually
really small
so let me pull some of this up this is a
daily wire poll most americans oppose
oscar's diversity requirements they say
the majority of americans don't believe
in diversity requirements
don't believe diversity requirements
should be a significant factor in
whether or not a film is nominated for
an oscar
at the academy awards according to the
findings of a new survey monkey poll
commissioned by the daily wire they say
63 of respondents agreed
that films should solely be judged on
their artistic merits
while only 24 of respondents say
diversity should be a significant factor
in a film's nominate in a film's
nomination the other respondents
indicated they were unsure
nearly half of non-white respondents 40
said artistic merit should be the sole
consideration
while 38 said diversity should be
factored in
the nomination decision to me i am not
surprised the ratings are in the gutter
it's not just the ratings for for
hollywood cnn news outlets or ratings
are in the gutter
fox news apparently the only outlet
that's actually maintained their ratings
post trump though they did take a big
hit
you know during trump like they had they
had some pushback during the election
right right right i look at i look at
these these tv shows and you see the
ratings are down
you look at the grammys you look at the
oscars nobody wants to watch this stuff
you look at some of these movies that
have come out and
wow have they not made money birds of
fray did you see that movie
no no you're lucky
it's not for the flight back i should
not uh you do not want to watch that
movie
no it is you know the issue i take with
it
is that it's all based off of this um
it's like it's like indignation like
like i'm uh it's this anger
yeah it's not a a positive question
so i think back to like you know old
content old shows back in the day that i
thought were progressive or in a sense
or
or talk to civil rights for things for
kids that that were done right
i always reference static shock the
cartoon i don't know if you're familiar
with no no
i mean it was a kids show and you have
um this this
character virgil hawkins he's a young
black teenager he gains superpowers
the stories they go through are about
you know his best friend is gay
should he join a gang and it was done in
a very inquisitive way that explained a
point
today's version of of politics in in
shows like wokeness and diversity
requirements are
bashing you over the head with anger
about how you're evil and wrong and
we're mad at you
yeah it's very very different from just
telling someone what what would be right
you know what i mean well i think
part of it is because getting back to
your might makes right argument
earlier one would hope that in a
civilized society we can all just
persuade one another through arguments
that hey
my view of this social question is right
and so here's my argument
but because the left has now basically
abandoned that and
and i don't just mean they don't make
good arguments and their arguments are
no good i mean
as a product of their radical ideologies
over the years they have come to
deny the reality of objective of the
objective world right they'll actually
say things like
objective truth that's actually a white
supremacist dog whistle
things like that so if they're going to
deny that
then argument falls apart and so it has
to be angry or at least threatening in
the sense that
if they want to get you to go along with
their program they've just got to make
you do it they're not going to persuade
you it won't be gentle at what point do
you legislate this
i was thinking of this earlier you were
saying like do you have the right to
tell someone i think you should do this
and yes i believe you do when if it's
not
a certain type of like sedition or
whatever but at what point
are you should you be able to legislate
i think you should do this and that's
basically kind of what our government
does and now it's what our social media
is doing because it's the new it's one
of the new forms of government because
it is the government
yeah right how are they legislating by
like public opinion by like
fear-mongering like this juror was
afraid that they were gonna
well so so it's it's the anger it's the
negativity it's the rage
instead of the compassion so a good
example i'm trying to think of like
what's a really good example of how they
do wokeness wrong and how about
ghostbusters 2016.
have you seen that one nobody saw that
one right yeah i don't think i'm alone
here
uh awful why because
they think that the idea of of diversity
in movies
is being mean and nasty and insulting
yeah so they're mad that we do captain
america we do thor and iron man and it's
all white males yeah
i don't care that it's white males i
have no problem with you know shang chi
the new it's the new marvel movie coming
out it's an asian lead with asian
characters i'm like
cool when you do when they see that
those three movies where it's all white
men
their reaction is to make a movie where
they insult and berate
and and belittle white men yeah it's
like how that's not social justice
that's just the same thing but just be
it just being mean to people you're
right
i think about a movie like wonder woman
the first one or
say like edge of tomorrow where they
actually just have
strong female characters to represent
female characters
and they don't insult you and bash over
the head and tell you're a [ __ ] or
you're toxic or you're stupid
to me that's that's the main issue here
but well you i mean it's
a good rule of thumb i've found is that
when you're trying to understand
something the radical left is doing
just invert reality invert the
traditional order so
uh traditionally what uh humility is the
beginning of wisdom right
very important virtue what does the left
celebrate pride
not just not just gay pride it's like
fat pride skinny pride [ __ ] pride all
right all these
all these various marches to to embrace
pride
which a friend of mine once said it used
to be thing i think it was thomas
aquinas called it the queen of all
vices and now uh my friend referred to
it as the vice of all queens which i
think that's very
that's not nice that's not a nice thing
it's very politically correct but it's
because it's actually it's way beyond
the gay question
if you look at the essence of
christianity what is it
that in this fallen world you have the
incarnation of perfect
good the actual god himself the second
person of the trinity incarnate into the
world to redeem mankind
what do you have on the left you have
the exact inversion of that you have
no shot at redemption no shot at the
incarnation of the good but you do have
the incarnation of evil
in in the character of the straight
white
man who knows that he's a man who right
it keeps getting narrower and narrower
we yeah we talked about this before the
show a little bit moral frameworks yeah
and uh
something i've definitely mentioned on
the show that there are a lot of
liberals in this country who are like
if you need religion to be moral then
like
i'm scared of you know what you really
think it's or like what you would do
with that religion you must be crazy
yeah and the example of bill maher who
would say something like i don't need
religion to have morals
and they don't realize that their morals
are built upon the judeo-christian
framework
right of course well of course i mean
the it's always so sophomoric when that
when that fad happened in the mid
2000s you know the new atheists i i
always felt the old atheists were a lot
more impressive i mean
i tried reading some of their books they
were sophomoric i mean they were so
shallow that they weren't even making
the arguments they thought that they
were making and someone like bill maher
yes where does bill maher get his
morality from his civilization which is
built on
christianity you can use the phrase
judeo christian whatever you want he was
raised i guess in a jewish household who
knows literally like benjamin franklin
and thomas jefferson you know
individuals who are fairly religious
individuals
to say the least it's built on
judeo-christians and a little bit of
moral or
i guess you call it authoritarian
militantism
like what do you mean well we just
massacred the native americans to form
our country and pride like we're talking
about humility
i don't think that's fair i don't think
that's fair think about america
right hold on okay we're we're talking
about
there are certain things that uh in the
bible
and the torah yeah humility and the
americans are a humble place but what we
that's a good place it's the place that
makes donald trump they talk about pride
trump represents like turning american
culture up to 11. it's like yeah the
epitome of
but yeah it comes from
i think uh decay of that moral framework
well where does pride what is what is
the american thing with pride because
humility is a virtue
and pride is a sin you know i actually i
think america is a humble country and
what and i actually think even trump is
politically
one of the most humble politicians we've
ever heard not because he doesn't have
an ego he slaps his name on every
building he ever saw
but it's because he understands that
there are limits to politics and there's
limits to what he can do i mean when he
comes in he says look
you know i'm a flawed guy but i fix
things we're gonna make it a little bit
better conservatives traditionally have
this idea
you can't remake the world into this
utopia to me that's a very
very humble position i think we can rag
on trump for his character
and persona as a representation of some
of the worst things like turning
american culture up to the 11 and just
really blasting the saturation he turns
over the casinos and the supermarkets
right right
but politically trump wouldn't send the
the the military or the feds into these
riots yeah he wouldn't he
he there were so many things trump
should have done he wouldn't do he
wouldn't fire people
he wouldn't force his way and they kept
screaming as a fascist
when he literally wouldn't do these
things in fact donald trump shut down
the child detention centers
yeah and joe biden reopened him yeah so
he built it
look trump i would not say is could be
described as
humble not at all strikes me as prideful
as it's all get out there's his name on
buildings he's all like i'm the best
like that's pride and
what holds america when it comes to
politics and the actions he took as a
president
absolutely he was more humble than say
joe biden was joe biden can rhetorically
be humble
that's a fact donald trump was the
opposite of him i don't think either of
those guys could to be a cult leader
shuts down the facilities you know why
donald trump shut down the child
facilities because the left was yelling
at him donald trump banned
stocks because the left was yelling at
him joe biden tells the right to screw
themselves well let me obama similarly
let me develop this a little because i
think pride
is an american virtue in a lot of ways
it's a catholic sin
but it's in the united states it's like
proud to be an american
and they teach you that as a kid they
taught me that as a kid that yes you
want to be prideful of your things and
it's good
and in a lot of ways it it does help you
succeed
in a capitalist society but do you think
when when i say
i mean it just seems to me we're using
this word pride in different ways like
when i say i'm proud to be an american
aren't we just talking about love of
country
patriotism it's sort of an extension of
filial piety like
i i agree there's a degree of national
pride that's a really bad thing when you
say like every other country is awful
and we're just gonna
take them all over and everything but in
a way america
i think doesn't do that we bomb the
middle east a lot but i i don't know
that we do that
we kind of open our country up we say
hey man come on in we want all the best
from everywhere all
right we let in more immigrants than any
other country don't we i mean the
the movement of immigrants into this
country over the last 60 years
is the largest movement of people ever
on earth in the history of the world so
yeah yeah people love it
and we let a lot of people in i mean so
much so that
now it's become very difficult if not
impossible to
to assimilate all you're talking about
millions of people every single year
and if you even raise the prospect of
hey maybe we should you know like
cool it a little bit until we assimilate
everybody
most people will look at you like you're
crazy you think the catholic church just
told people pride is bad because they
wanted to keep control of people
no well pride pride made satan fall like
lightning from heaven you know i mean
pride is the
it's the sin of in the garden of eden
actually whitaker chambers ex-communist
who wrote this great book witness which
actually helped bring ronald reagan from
the left to the right
he said that communism is not a new
ideology communism is the second oldest
faith of mankind it's the great
alternative faith
that began in the garden when the
serpent told adam and eve
ye shall be his gods and that
presumption to be
as a god is it that is the bible story
that is what causes the fall so i
you know i think it's in the heart of
man i don't think it's uniquely american
but we've all got it there's no doubt
about that
we we've stumbled onto this talk about
america and we were talking about
hollywood
so i'm going to make this segment happen
because i'm so excited for this
the first thing i want to say is this if
if i could offer you up
all of you guys listening a tv show
where a guy takes an american flag
and brutally beats antifa and
you know he rejects a bunch of woke
ideas he's repeatedly told by
you know people about how uh you know
you know you you shouldn't you shouldn't
wave that flag it's the white man's flag
and that you got to understand and so
you have this this black man who says no
i like the flag and he picks it up
and then there are these people who are
like we should have open borders and
we're gonna we're gonna smash the flag
and then he just beats him with it
would that be a show conservatives would
want to watch it sounds great
where do i sign up where do i get it
it's the falcon and the winter soldier
so first let me show this story from we
got this covered
that we talked about i think a couple
weeks ago new rumor says over 80
of falcon in winter soldier viewers
turned off episode two at the same point
now i'm talking about this you know
we're talking about hollywood wokeness
the commercialization of this anger
and i i got to talk about the show and i
think pride fits in
because i'm wondering why it is i see a
lot of people saying this show is woke
don't watch it it's awful it's racist
people don't want to watch it and i
wonder if there's an element of pride in
assuming hollywood does this so not
maybe not giving it a chance yeah maybe
being being a little more open-minded so
we have this this this
segment from uh marvel.com or this
article
cast and creative creatives behind the
falcon winter soldier discussed
patronism
supremacy captain america's mantle and
you have this this quote from anthony
mackie
who plays excuse me he plays
the falcon he says for sam it's a
constant battle of how do you fight for
a country that's never fought for you
remarks anthony mackie explaining in
many ways the one thing that held up the
moniker of that shield was the idea of
who steve rogers was which is captain
america
that that comment to me was really
interesting because it does i think in
many ways show that marvel
they're woke and they don't get it for
anthony mackie to say that a country
never fought for you i mean i think one
of the bloodiest battles in the history
of the world was the civil war right
quite literally to end slavery among
other you know
peripheral factors but that was a key
component but here's what i got to say
about this show
and what hollywood is doing and what we
need to be careful of i'm seeing a lot
of people tell me i'm wrong cause i said
the show's not woke
i'm like it's not woke give it a chance
it's actually my it's fairly centrist
it addresses issues of race but quite
literally
i'm going to spoil the show for those
who haven't seen the finale because the
felony finale came out and i was
so excited watching a dude reject
wokeness
pick up the american flag and and beat
antifa with it
i mean that like i don't literally like
antifa getting beaten but the bad guys
are called flag smashers
yeah they want open borders they they're
terrorists who kill people
they think might makes right and because
they have super strength they're allowed
to kill whoever they want
she literally says to that there's a
soldier with ptsd
you watch his best friend who's a black
man get killed and she says his life
doesn't matter
and i was like that's an amazing
indictment of
these fake woke antifa who would use
someone for political points if they
could get ahead and then literally tell
you to your face they don't matter
anthony mackie plays a black man who
questions whether or not he should wear
the american flag
ultimately decides to do it and they
even show a scene
where there is there's another black man
who says no self-respecting black men
would wear that shield
and anthony mackie says i know those
people who'll be mad at me for wearing
this
but you know he wants to fight for this
country and he'll be damned if someone
tells him he can't do it
and then he he's literally wearing the
american flag
chasing down open borders extremists i'm
like i'm sorry i mean
there's definitely a message about
racism being bad but it sounds like a
more
classically liberal or even a
conservative statement about why racism
is bad
well it's obviously conservative in the
sense that america is good and the flag
smashers are bad i mean just in the most
basic sense
that is a conservative message right
you're going to make me
i was at one and a half marvel products
that's what i had you're going to make
me go to two and a half now
i certainly think there's elements that
people could call woke but i wonder if
what a lot of people i did say i tweeted
it was getting too woke
and it was after this point where a car
pulls up as a squad car pulls up and you
got you know anthony mackey and you got
falcon and bucky barnes
a white guy a black guy and it was this
very stereotypically like racist moment
where the cops were like sir are you all
right to the white dude
a lot of people got mad about that yeah
but i'm like
uh i'm gonna watch it because i don't
want to fall into this trap where i'm
like that's what i woke i won't watch it
yeah and then i was amazingly surprised
there was a point where apparently you
know sam sam wilson the falcon
black man is is you know
bucky barnes apologizes saying i didn't
realize what it meant for a black man to
wear you know that shield and be captain
america
but he's like i don't he doesn't want to
do that he has a little kid tell him
he's walking on the street little kid
goes it's black falcon and he goes nah
i'm just a falcon
and the kid goes no my dad says you're
black falcon he goes i'm just the falcon
and i'm like you are just the falcons
yeah like your racism
is not relevant to you being a superhero
who's awesome yeah and when he decided
to defy
people in this black community who said
you think you can come in here because
you have that white man's shield
and he's like but i like that guy he was
cool with my friend he's like steve
rogers didn't do this to you
and then he decides to wear the american
flag representing the country
even aft for every reason he felt like
he he was wrong by this country or
didn't fight for him
for every you know for everyone telling
him that america was bad and doesn't
represent him and hates him
he still believed in this country and
i'm like
it's like hardcore nationalists yeah
it's like it's like almost trumpian in a
way i'm actually i'm wondering if it's
chinese propaganda in that they have now
incited antiqua to go riot and burn
things down for a couple years now
they're going to start making art about
why we should fight them
yeah it's the it's the 4d chess of the
chinese communists yeah
i i did think about this and i wonder to
what extent there's a conspiracy in
media
now that the election's over they need
to stop antifa
and start putting out messages about
loving the country and
getting things back on track because you
know we were promised the riots would
stop once joe biden came in and they
ain't stopping they're getting worse
yeah well that is the problem when you
when you unleash
violence you don't get to control it you
know actually things say this is
when you begin a war you know things
quickly spiral out of
out of control and that that's clearly
what's going on here but i i am
i'm actually glad you told me this about
marvel because conservatives do this a
lot where they
they'll see a little because because
we're so abused because this whole
culture
abuses and abuses just smacks us all the
time
we just said the minute we see someone
say okay that's all i'm done i'm done i
can't take it anymore
and there was that movie that came out i
don't even remember the name of it it
was supposed to come out a few years ago
and it was about how these white rich
liberals
you know i don't even know if it was all
white people it was the hunt right it
was really good
it seemed great i mean the whole thing
was these these rich coastal libs
were hunting down good regular americans
and
you know i thought this is the most
conservative movie ever made i only saw
the trailer
and then there was a backlash from not
from libs it was from conservatives who
said how dare you hunt me down you think
like
do you get the point of the movie yeah
even trump came out
trump that's right even i came out and
my point was
i think we're in too divisive of a time
to be making a video where liberals are
kidnapping and hunting down
conservatives
they might think it's a it's like a nice
movie yeah it's a plan
yeah right so i was like i don't want to
see that thing and then i did
and it was as i would say it's it's
actually
not partisan it's good there was like
it made fun of everybody yeah and i'll
say this about falcon and winter soldier
maybe it's conservative like you should
watch it and tell me what you think you
know
but i think it's actually fairly
centrist i think it's fairly la it's not
trying to
in many ways it opposes wokeness yeah
but it does address
the the animosity and the feelings of
racism in in an interesting way
so i think there's a lot of people who
who i'll put it this way
to me wokeness represents insulting
denigrating beating someone over the
head yeah telling them they're stupid or
evil or wrong or privileged
whereas actual social justice as a
as i understood it would be like someone
calmly and explaining to you with
respect
how they feel when it comes to racism
wow so when you go woke it's really
you're going you're getting angry well
but you're but you're
it's almost like if i was if i was going
to insult you and say you're you know
you're stupid this person that person
your identity
that to me is like what we see with
wokeness it's this idea that
white people have some kind of inherent
badness to them or something
that whiteness represents more like it's
the most insane thing so you could take
on social justice
i think you shouldn't be twerking for
kids but if you start going
you're an idiot for twerking for kids
then you're becoming woke
it's it's well there's there's a couple
things one i think a lot of wokeness is
a quest for power not a quest for
compassion certainly
so you're wrong bend your knee or else
i'll take your job away
yeah whereas what i see in the falcon
winter soldier is
you know there's one guy who uh one of
the characters
seems to me to represent wokeness
animosity towards white people
and the american flag and the main
character rejects that and says no i
like this flag i'm going to fight for
this country
well you know it's it's all negat
everything you've just described is
purely negative right
wokeness is this purely negative
campaign and it's that's just the new
term for political correctness there's
all sorts of terms part of what the left
does is just change the terms all the
time so
that's the new one but it gets back to
something that karl marx said
which is getting back to quoting karl
marx every so often
karl marx in a letter uh in
oh gosh i forget the year he called for
the ruthless
criticism of all that exists and this
was taken up later by
radical marxist theorists and a
practical politician antonio gramsci
in his construction of uh what you'd
call cultural hegemony western marxism
this is taken up in the frankfurt school
and critical theory
which is now we see the derivation of
critical race theory it's dominated the
universities that
is the woke indoctrination comes from
critical theory
and once you get past all the
pretentious jargon
in these crazy things what is the theory
it's very simple the theory is to
criticize
it's the same thing marx called for it's
just because guess what
i i've noticed this about bigots you
know
my friend andrew clavin points this out
a lot bigots
are not always wrong about the other guy
they're just
wrong about themselves you know they're
really good at criticizing everybody
else
but they don't see their own flaws
everything is susceptible to criticism
so it's a very
very easy sort of new pseudo-academic
discipline
and there's no end to it it's just
rubble is going to be the end of it i i
think
you know one of one of the ways to look
at it is uh
i had a conversation with about trump a
bunch of trump supporters over dinner
when i was in i think i was in
california
this was during like the trump campaign
era i think it was uh maybe just after i
got elected
and i was talking about historical
racism
and immediately the reaction was like
laughter and like you know oh yeah yeah
and i was like
i was like legit no like i mean
sincerely i mean seriously
you're not joking and then i explained
to them like redlining and blockbusting
yeah where we actually have legit racist
policies in this country that have a
negative impact on communities
you know of color into the uh into the
modern era
but institutionally we've actually made
that all illegal yeah however the
remnants still exist
and so the way i see it is when i treat
people with respect
and say just hear me out on this because
i want to understand you
you get respect back that's that that i
think is totally fine
i i actually have no problem with seeing
that in a tv show the issue is when
instead of saying like michael let me
explain to you something about my
experience
they say you're a stupid white man nazi
fascist and like when movies are
predicated upon
berating and insulting you yeah that's
get well go bro well you know the the
late philosopher roger scrutin pointed
this out he said civilization
thrives on forgiveness
on confession first and then forgiveness
and when i confess that i've done
something wrong
even if it's confessing historical
wrongs at the national level whatever
i sacrifice my pride and when you
forgive me
you sacrifice your resentment and we we
have both sacrificed something that we
cherish
that really means a lot to us and that's
the only way you can move forward but if
you're not going to get that if you're
going to have a whole culture
permeated by resentment where you get it
ever you get it in school
you get it in sometimes as a matter of
law and you get it even when you want to
relax and go to the movies and that's
all you get
it's pride right right it's really
interesting because i've had so many
experiences where
i i've always been very confident in
myself
i don't need to justify or validate
myself to others
and so i just you know i don't but
there's a lot of people who are proud
yeah they need others to know how good
they are how big they are
and it gets them in trouble well you
know true humility does away with false
modesty there are some there's some
people who can't take a compliment
that's just another form of pride
right that's just a kind of that's just
the flip side of it but but true
humility you can say yeah okay i did
this right this was all right you know
hey thanks man it's cool
moving on focusing on other things
trying to move forward in 2006 i decided
to use youtube videos as a form of
confession
and i started making videos about my
past and my history and the mistakes and
the lies i've told
and it allowed me to clear my mind i was
able to start thinking
full complete sentences and i had i
could have a silent mind now
you're a braver man than i am when i
want to confess i go into a little
black box with a scrim where i change my
voice and stuff
that's very great ridiculed so hard
for so many years to this day i will
still i still get comments on those
videos they're all up online and i would
introduce
why'd you do it if you don't mind my
social experiment i thought someone
could what would jesus do with this
technology
yeah he would consistently prostrate
himself to the to the humanity and beg
them to come together
so i tried that pride go with before the
fall
yes i was like i remember that i gotta
look that up i
i i think about that especially in the
context of news all of these journalists
are so desperate for validation yeah
their pride consumes them they won't
admit when they're wrong they refuse to
be wrong and they'd rather win above all
else
we need humility desperately yeah but we
the the problem is because i agree oh if
only we could do that and you could
everyone would just confess and it'd be
cool right
but the the problem is right now with
with cancel culture which is a real
phenomenon
it's it's a it's a very specific
phenomenon it's a leftist phenomenon
when the left says well you know in the
50s conservatives canceled communists
yep we did that was awesome
that's great every society has
boundaries but what's going on right now
is that if you go wave the flag
the american flag or you don't go along
with some woke
fashion to castrate kids or something
then you lose your job that is cancel
culture
and if you uh
in any way admit that you're wrong let's
say you actually legitimately do
something wrong i
on occasion have done that and i i wish
that i could apologize for that
you you can't because the minute that
you apologize
you're dead they will never forgive you
you saw with the guy who hosted the
bachelor
you saw it with all a number of other
journalists sometimes
you're dead there's so you so what do
you have to do you you simply cannot
enact that humility yep it's an
admission of guilt
it's an admission of guilt and you won't
there's no redemption so you gotta yeah
i lost i was in hollywood as an actor
and after i started doing that no one
would cast me they thought i was like
dangerous
that which i was because i would call i
would have called them out and destroyed
that you got to keep the secrets
disgusting secretive community i would
have and uh they knew that look look at
uh
you know harvey people do for they do
forgive
but if you're if you have a job that you
can lose you'll probably lose it
if you go that route if you try to be
humble um if you work for yourself
you're in a much better position
and youtube ads you know you can kind of
work for yourself there i don't know i'm
getting off on a tangent
well you can you you can build a
business but i find it fascinating that
uh
the the left i think is consumed by
pride
yes i think that's that's a big factor
and i think when you are you can't admit
when you're wrong
yeah and if you can't admit when you're
wrong you can't improve yourself will
you ever notice this about stupid people
is stupid people think that they're
really really smart
and then smart people the first thing
you notice about smart people
is that they're very aware of how stupid
they are and it's not false modesty
they're actually aware of it because
maybe i don't know maybe the smart
person met a smarter person one time
and just kind of put it all into
perspective it is a it is a
fail proof uh the rule of thumb the the
loudest voices in the room who are
there there they are they are never
admit that they're wrong listen to
people to discern that for yourself
because if a smart person says something
that a stupid person doesn't understand
the stupid person will
tell the smart person they're not making
any sense and that they're the students
this is buckowski bukowski yes
the problem with the world is that the
intelligent people are full of doubts
while the stupid ones are full of
confidence
see i didn't even know that i didn't
even know that book the big bukowski
that's a great movie
getting back to movies yeah that's a
great one so what do we do are we so we
just humiliate ourselves
no no well you don't want to humiliate
yourself you just you're fortunate i
mean
yeah but there's a difference there's a
day you know when you humiliate yourself
you
you no longer have any uh dignity you're
sort of offending your own dignity
when christ says for instance uh love
your neighbor as you love yourself well
if you
hate yours if you truly hate yourself uh
then
you know it's not gonna be great for
your neighbor so there is there is a
recognition of human dignity here i mean
that kind of explains a lot of leftism
leftism as well a lack of
self-confidence a a lack
of understanding who you are and that
same level is translated to other people
they also have no empathy or sympathy
for there's also
virtue advice are real things it's not
just your opinion man
they really are real things and i do
think there's a lot of shame
i mean you know all this shout your
abortion nonsense or the [ __ ] walks or
whatever is
the lady doth protest too much me thinks
right
i mean clearly something is annoying at
them and i i say this is
at various times in my life you know i
was an atheist for 10 years and i acted
like it you know you you can
really give yourself over more to just
kind of doing whatever you want
vices and all this there are other times
when you try to avoid that you try to
tame your will down and i will just tell
you
it's better there is there is a reason
that
people have long sought the virtuous
life and
if you have a country that is just
wracked by this
shame and this guilt and this resentment
this anger and this
self-hatred and they don't know what to
do with that
you're gonna it's like a powder keg it's
gonna pop maybe we need uh
what was it called bushido was that the
the lukowski
lebowski no yes wait what was that
ancient japanese honor
honor
no i'm talking about like um honor
yeah you know uh let me throw in a star
trek reference while i get the chance
oh boy the the the uh you know i
absolutely
uh i'm a huge fan of star trek you're
friends you fantasize i've never seen
even a single property in the original
star trek
there were uh you've heard of klingons
i'd imagine yes
so the federation is a a
united federation of planets it's very
much reminiscent of the idea of america
with
classically liberal values and there are
klingons and oh they're enemies
when the next generation was made which
was you know i think 1989 or 88 89 maybe
they uh all the trackers aren't even mad
at me for not knowing the exact year
they they the show starts with a klingon
serving on board a federation ship
to show that in the time span from the
first series to the second
peace has been achieved in the story
what happened was
a distress signal was sent out by a
klingon colony that was being attacked
by romulans yeah
aliens started attacking killing women
and children the federation
enterprise of its era went in without
help and they all died trying to save
their enemies
and the klingons saw that as a great act
of honor because they're a culture of
honor and warriors
and so that's what ignited a peace
agreement i just bring that up because
i'm really that story is so awesome this
is amazing writing
yeah about how how honor actually
like what what it really meant and that
you had this war-like warrior race
that watched these you know classically
liberal federation types say like we're
going we're probably gonna die
yeah but we want to save our our own
enemies i think back to these stories
about batman and superman refusing to
kill at all costs because
it was it was it was about what was true
to them what was what was right
and what was honorable and now we have a
moral framework
yeah in wokeness that's built upon just
having power
which means they will sacrifice you they
will they will they will they will
figuratively burn you at the stake
because they want power
there's no honor but honor honor doesn't
it couldn't possibly exist because
we're actually told these two
contradictory frameworks right these two
contradictory anthropologies one of
which is
we're meat puppets and all of these
metaphysical things like honor love
joy dreams it's all just delusions it's
just synapses firing in our brain it's
just a joke right so that's one story
we're told then we're told the total
opposite story which is that gnostic
story that actually
the ultimate reality is just my
innermost self
that is whatever i want whatever i
perceive is
is reality but there too there's no such
thing as honor it's just my
my willfulness as you say and
i think part of the reason they tell us
to believe in both of these
contradictory ideas at the same time
is what orwell described as doublethink
he says double think
the the thing about doublethink is it
makes you unwilling and unable to reason
because you got to hold the two
contradictory ideas at the same time but
both of them exclude
the the real world that you're
describing which is oh there's something
beyond my will there there is such a
thing and
we can deny it all we want but you know
i recognize it when i see it
there's such a thing as honor now let's
break down
you know the the the the connection
batman won't kill superman won't kill
they've had their stories where they
have for sure but the general idea
yeah and why it was the story was
written i'm not saying that klingons are
real
it was written by people in the united
states who believed in the value of it
imagine you have a moral framework
framework that understands honor
in this the batman won't kill the joker
excellent writers have explored what
happens when you have people with no
honor
meeting people with honor and in one of
the one of the story lines
in uh in the dc universe is that the
joker poisoned superman
and then detonates a nuclear device
killing millions
and superman has a psychotic break where
he says if you just
killed him this would have never
happened if you choose to sacrifice
yourself to save your own enemy
and they don't share your morals they'll
laugh as you do it
and then slit your throat once once
you've saved them they you will you will
pull them up from the cliff
because you're the good guy with honor
who says i must save even the bad guy
and then as soon as you do they'll try
and push you off the edge so you have
people in the united states right now
i being a fan of star trek and these
stories of batman and these these you
know there's
just stories for kids but it inspired me
and it
made me understand what was honorable
and moral that means
i'm not willing to lie cheat or steal
yeah but it means the other moral
framework of might makes right from the
woke
they absolutely will especially during
times of war with you look at the
british
and the revolutionary war for instance
the british were fighting lines standing
up
out in the open honorably and the and
the americans were hiding in the woods
stealing
lying false orders that is mostly a myth
there it really was a lot of the same
thing
the like meeting on battlefields i guess
but we did adopt some guerrilla tactics
yeah to enhance your point lying
cheating and stealing was george
washington's
forte like he was an outrageous calumny
no i disagree with that i'm sorry he was
a spy he would send false orders in line
and confuse the enemy the armies used
spies as all armies dude
george washington is one of the most
virtuous men who has ever walked
but he was a killer he was a killer but
he was a justified killer and i i mean i
think this is
this is what we're getting at here which
is the
the honor of it all means well you say
okay i want to be honorable
and uh but then if my k if my enemy
doesn't recognize that honor he's going
to slip my throat and what a fool i am
he's going to laugh at me
yeah but it's we thought we still do it
and you
you have to recognize you can't fake it
i guess is what i'm saying
there it's very popular right now i've
noticed in the kind of
center and some disaffected liberals and
on the right to say man all those old
things we used to have like dignity and
honor
and religion and all you know that i i
know that that's
good but i can't bring myself to believe
in it douglas murray says this a lot the
the british writer
he'll say look i'm a christian atheist
you know basically i think it's good but
i can't bring myself to believe in it
and the thing is i sympathize with these
people
who know that it's a good thing but they
can't bring themselves to actually
believe in it
you can't fake it you actually have to
believe that there is an objective moral
order
that the joker he's gonna he's gonna get
his just desserts
he's gonna get his comeuppance maybe not
in this life but in the life to come
that that there actually is a an
objective good it's not just a
sort of nice social thing that we all
agree on to have a good society because
if you just pretend then i think when it
comes down to it the real rubber meets
the road
it's going to fall we're we're we're
about to jump to super chats but i want
to tell you my um
my kind of i don't know i don't know
what you'd call it
religious view or so so first uh i
absolutely believe in god
and i think one of the challenges a lot
of people have when it comes to the idea
of god
is that they have i guess i'm not trying
to be disrespectful but a child's view
of what god would be
yeah big man in the sky exactly as
opposed to a force beyond human
imagination like you can't even conceive
of what outside of time and space
which which by the way not not to
interrupt but if god is to exist at all
he must in his fullness be
incomprehensible because if you could
cram them into your little head he just
by definition wouldn't be god exactly
you know so i i think that's the first
mistake people make and that they assume
when people talk about god it's a guy
with a beard sitting on a cloud and i'm
like you know like a child would imagine
it or
a com a comedian would depict it so i i
definitely believe
in in god but i think this you you
mentioned you
we have to view that we have to believe
that joker will get his comeuppance
yeah there's something else that drives
me towar in all this and i started
thinking about this a while ago about
what's the point of life what is what
why is
white is life i can't tell you um
because it's a great philosophical
question that i don't think you know we
are but
small little me i could give you an
answer yeah to know god and enjoy him
forever
that's the that's the catechism so from
from
my understanding of philosophy the
things i have read the things i think i
understand that view especially having
grown up catholic but i started to think
about
i i need i need a function right like
let me try and look at the universe to
to what we claim to know about it
and we certainly don't know much and a
lot of these ideas are probably wrong
that's what science does it gets things
wrong and then improves upon them later
and i started thinking about entropy and
negative entropy
and i started thinking about what life
does organizing free energy into
complex systems from the most
rudimentary of self-replicating proteins
to single-celled organisms to
multi-celled organisms
to beyond that with ecosystems where
at first you have a multicellular
organism consuming free energy
and literally converting it into a
replica of itself
and expanding and having more and more
kids and then eventually you know 10
fish becomes 100 fish
they're converting those particles into
fish they're organizing things they're
creating
eventually you get abstract creations
like an ecosystem where beavers start
manipulating their environment
and then you know an acorn falls and a
squirrel plants it for the winter but
forgets where it is and then a tree
grows
then you get humans who start creating
creating complex systems in in the
abstract languages
ideas they start mapping the universe i
thought to myself
creation but not not in the sense that
we can quick because we can't we can
only change things
we're procreators yeah we're not right
we're not actual creators
so i think to me what i find to be
the the simple driving factor in all of
this is that we are a force for good
and what is that good it is to fix
things
to protect things to organize things to
grow things to learn things
and that's the most simple way i could
ever see it that
we organize we organize it's the most
rudimentary way to look at it however
think about what's good and what's bad
killing is wrong it horrifies people
it's the most
one of the most evil things a person can
do having children is one of the
greatest things
a person could do and so i think about
why
i would oppose the joker is because he
destroys
yeah he he hurts and he causes detriment
the one thing i see life doing is
creating
procreating developing and that's what
we should strive to do
well you're that's what you've just
given is not a simplistic answer i mean
it's a simple answer but it's not a
simplistic one
you're you're saying that you think that
the purpose in life is to pursue the
good
that that is just obviously true and you
know and you know
i'm when i give the answer that it's to
know god and enjoy him forever
that's just a more elaborate version of
that answer right which is that the
the good the true and the beautiful as
the transcendentals of
being or have some sort of relation to
one another and the ultimate expression
of that is
is in god and uh but your answer is
totally right i think you have to
complicate it though because in order to
grow
children you have to kill and consume so
destruction is a part of this
organization yes
in order to have negative entropy you
must create more entropy but
we are i think i think i agree with you
in that what we are what we are doing as
a species is we are getting
to the best of our ability to to try and
know god i think in my opinion
we are here because god wants us to
project and protect and create and grow
and through our expansion of knowledge
and philosophy and understanding we are
coming to know god better and better
have you ever seen climatics
in action have you ever seen kymatics
it's when sound
vibrates a membrane with like rice on it
and the membrane the rice
and that's i think what god this this
universal vibration is like
making our bodies behave a certain way i
don't know if fate is real
i don't know how you feel about fate and
free will and if we're just
i think providence is real and free will
is also real and that's a complicated uh
you know situation but yeah surely there
is there is a
an order to things and there is a
providence and an unfolding of reality
let's put attack in this and we'll do
the the bonus segment because we can go
a lot longer because we do have to do
super chats
yeah a lot of people have questions for
you michael but uh then we can do a
this is gonna be fun i'm gonna take all
of michael malus questions on that super
chat i don't care how many come in i
want them all michael malice's
yeah all right we got uh jordan jones he
said oh
if you haven't already get your super
chats in we'll read as many as we can
smash the like button become a member at
timcast.com we'll have a bonus segment
coming up we're going to talk about
philosophy god probably dmt
a lot of dmt
yeah let's talk about it all right we'll
do that so go to teamcast.com sign up
and uh let's read some super chats we
got jordan jones he says
michael knowles i'm still subscribed
over to the daily wire almost entirely
because i enjoy your content
keep triggering libs and doing what you
do
thanks man you hear that ben by the way
that was a subscriber only there for me
don't you don't you tow my car in the
parking lot
you know uh i enjoy the triggering of
libs and cons
i think they're huge they're great i
think people who get triggered
ben is really good at not being
triggered yeah and that's enjoyable when
ben rolls with the punches
and you gotta do it so trigger away yeah
thank you appreciate it threadian says
michael i bought your first
i bought your first book for our white
elephant exchange a few years ago
and it was a monstrous hit thank you you
know
it is funny with that the blank book
it's called reasons to vote for
democrats a comprehensive guy it's
totally blank
and i just did it to irritate my
democrat friends and relatives
i thought i'd sell like 20 copies or
something but the fact is
much like thucydides it is not for the
applause of the moment it is an eternal
contribution for all time it remains
true every single year
truer and truer by the year so thank you
i'm glad it was a hit
i know you like you just bragged to ben
so i'll read you this one
rampton says can y'all have andrew
clavin next time instead real nice
goodnight everybody hey you chased my
guest away
all right here we go 3d pyromaniac says
let's see how long until nulls plugs his
newest book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available
now for pre-order on amazon at least
until they find out what it says
wow that sounds like a very could you
repeat the name of that book that's so
interesting
i i don't i don't even need to plug it
i've got i've got all these wonderful
people
it's called speechless controlling words
controlling minds it's available now for
pre-order oh very quick
on amazon right until until they ban it
yeah speechless
because we have the best audience uh of
any podcast
andrew you says star trek next
generation season 4 episode 21 drumhead
picard has to stop a witch hunt on the
enterprise fits so close to what the
left does based on politics
for real man and what you need to
understand about the next generation is
that it was just written by a bunch of
dudes
in the late 80s and early 90s in america
who held these values and
were explaining to them to people it's
amazing
man what a what what a great show
basically the show is someone's accused
i think this is
he's accused of is this the one where
they accuse the guy of being a spy then
they go around they want to prosecute
everybody and it's just lock them all up
because they're you know they're spies
papa bear says tim big fan i'm a veteran
libertarian and west virginian native
wokism is in our universities although
there are still some intelligent
professors
that's true man that's true it's only
getting worse
what is going on with this eli wood are
you are you guys having the daily wire
people send super chats
are they what are they doing what's he
saying i can't wait to see how many
times michael will plug his new book
speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-orders during
tonight's show
so i will say so my my book your
audience so
so i i've really conditioned them like
pavlov's dog i have because
so my book doesn't come out for two
months they're actually one of the big
tech companies
yeah but they're already kind of messing
with the publisher's advertising
campaign
so i started i knew this might happen so
i started plugging it seriously i
started plugging it like like three
months out
and but it's not just i'm not smooth
about it i am
i mean we're talking like frying pan
over the head
we so they actually the producers on my
show created a little bing
a little bell every time i do it and uh
it you know if i do it like four times
like the screen starts to shake
you know the universe starts to fall
apart so it's uh yeah it's a
pavlovian reaction yeah it's working
great so everyone's now super chatting
so that i read
and plug your book for you beautiful man
that's great
all right i'll fight you naked says i
wrote a piece on medium called letter to
awoke heart
you can cite all the facts and
statistics but that rarely makes a
difference
however if you can tell a story that
shows the end of the road they are going
down you have a chance
interesting yeah the issue is you know i
worked for these non-profits
not only did they train me how to
convince someone of your political
ideology
very quickly and very easily in a matter
of minutes on the street for someone
you've never met before yeah
i was also particularly good at it just
on my own but the problem i had was
one day it was when deepwater horizon
happened
they gave us our talking points and i
was reading about this and i was like
man this is bad now standing on the
street and i was talking to a guy
and i cited a number and he goes that's
not true and i was like
no no no yeah yeah it's it's like this
many gallons are spelling this right now
it's not
and then he pulled up his phone and he's
like no it was it it's it's you know
it's
this many number and i was like oh i'm
sorry i must have the wrong facts it's
like you're coming you're coming out
here trying to lie to me to get
to make me give you money and i was like
i'm sorry dude i had no idea but someone
must be getting something wrong
my apologies and he's like yeah whatever
and he walks away call the office and
they're like don't worry just keep
and saying it like nah you mean to tell
me you had me lying out here
wow and so i got really mad i thought i
was doing something good
i thought i found a job where i was like
i was gonna help and then it turns out i
was having their bottom line instead
yeah well because if the if the number
that they gave you
is a more persuasive story well that's
all they can right if you don't it's cnn
yeah that's right yeah it might have
been yeah were you working for cnn at
the time all right no but we did
fundraise like basically a block away
from them
yeah i was uh this was when i was out in
l.a yeah and then i was just like
yeah man this is not legit and i'll tell
you this
if i wanted to if if i thought the ends
justified the means
yeah oh man did me no question i'd do
whatever i wanted the problem is there
there are no ends
yeah it's you know it's the question of
um you know once you stage your glorious
revolution
how will you protect your how will you
protect from the next glorious
revolution yeah
you think you're justified using
violence deception and manipulation
today
then why would you stop doing it
tomorrow well it's perpetual
you know fidel castro when he's 92 years
old he's still wearing the military
fatigues like it's still the cuban
revolution 50 years later
do you think that um like along the
lines without glass guys super chatting
that you
in order to help people you're trying to
explain a potential end to the road that
is disastrous
to warn them i don't know
i don't know that's enough maybe this
like
falcon and winter soldier thing will
move people away from antifa
yeah yeah no and i mean it because maybe
what people people need to realize when
they're like oh it's woke it's really
bad maybe
from a conservative perspective it's got
too much social justice like oh you know
racism and whatever
but maybe to somebody who's been beaten
over that by the wokeness
you open the door by showing them
something they can relate to
hey racism is bad you know look the cops
are bad and then you have the villains
literally be antifa
yeah and then they're going to be like
captain america can stop you i believe
in america and the american flag
it's also don't forget the left it's not
that the left
loves antifa they recognize antifa is a
very dangerous thing that wants to burn
it all down
so they just use them they're the sort
of tactical military wing i think i
heard you describe it this way
i heard someone describe it this way
that antifa is effectively the militant
wing of the
the establishment but you got to reign
it in sometimes
when they're when they're causing more
harm than good you've got to reign them
in and maybe
maybe now they're kind of like okay you
know we had antifa for a few years it
helped us with trump and now we're gonna
you know maybe maybe tone it down a
little bit and cut him off and kick him
out
yeah we'll see how that plays out all
right chris pavado pivotal says as you
often say
fb knows when we use the bathroom or
other tracking ideas
would the government seriously touch
section 230 if
shared our info in the wild it's easier
for the prey to hunt
the weakest in packs as people are
socially divided and preoccupied
uh i don't know what you mean would they
touch section 230
maybe uh are you saying that as long as
facebook is allowed to operate with
impunity they can
steal ourselves they share it with the
government yeah all right if they share
information with the government then
they're going to protect their rights to
keep doing it yeah well there clearly
is a partnership between these big tech
firms and the government i actually
asked bill barr this question when he
was a.g
i said all right you're going to go
after section 230 he said all of the
about fraud section 230
all sorts of things that's what we
that's how we have to go after it
i said okay so why aren't you doing it
and he said
there is a procedural difficulty here
which is that
you'd be using different departments of
the federal government even within the
doj you'd be using different departments
and we've never done something like this
before that the the big tech companies
are a new thing
that's why they've been able to do
whatever they want
and the government is not particularly
good at uh taking on new challenges and
it's especially not good when it's
benefiting in some ways from these
challenges and so it was it kind of left
me a little crestfallen
and pessimistic about it because i don't
see the incentive and frankly i don't
even see the ability
of these bureaucrats and doj officials
to take him down
right on turk longwell says tim as a
patriot
as a marine vet as an american i loved
the last episode of falcon and winter
soldier
it's about being an american not skin
color
i completely agree i was i was so stoked
when he was like i'm gonna wear this
flag and go beat up these you know open
borders
you know black-clad individuals who
think they can do whatever they want
all right uh opossum says oh man i was
hoping the daily wire gas was gonna be
matt walsh
i saw some of that hold on i how do i
how do i
do my i'll do my best matt walter
impression just ask me anything
two plus two equals what's two plus two
equal
four yeah that's pretty much matt
yeah totally
i watched the candace owens first day
thing yeah stay out of my way
all right evil zombie hamster says
what's rachel maddow doing on the show
real nice
i thought it was going to be someone
from the daily wire jk love you michael
i listen to you almost every day you're
very kind i left my warby parkers at
home
just to avoid the comparison that that
mistake yes
i do love how they're paying to insult
you but also tell you
i'll take it
i know i either get people paying to
promote my book
or to call me a lesbian on msnbc
i love it that's your joke come and take
them says tim i sent a chat last week
re my film 10k investment in tim cast
production
multiple creators looking for help but
haven't received a reply via spin the
ufo
apology for the indelicacy but had the
follow uh but had the follow-up hope
y'all are well
pitches at timcast.com is now the email
and
just keep in mind for everybody we get a
ridiculous amount of emails
and we just we try to go through them
but you also gotta understand
a lot of people send like bad emails a
lot of people send really great ones and
we gotta sift through it and you know
figure out what we can get a lot of long
emails a lot of that's not so nice
emails
yeah all right let's see you
the fulcrum says tim did you see don
lemon and chris cuomo the other night
they
straight up take the side of the cop in
the columbus shooting lemon even says
tasers don't always work blew my mind
there was even a moment where chris
cuomo
said you can't yell fire at a crowded
theater and don lemon goes no
no that's not true yeah and he goes
chris you're a lawyer
you should know this and he's like no
you can't do that and don lemon i'm like
wow and lemon's correct you can yell
fire in a crowded theater
don lemon does this thing where if if
you look at don lemon
from like seven years ago he was
defending bill o'reilly sometimes
he was don lemon was was much more
moderate
and as with all those guys at cnn i
think they just for a while they said
okay you got to go far left and what do
they do
go far left go dance the pull in the
strings you know sad
and bob says two of the three people i
listen to daily wow i have crowders mug
michael's tumblr tim when will you
release your drinking vessel
p.s there's a timpool discord
well-moderated find on reddit
love you both and uh both and crew
actually i don't
i think there is already a tim cast mug
available
if you go to the store but it's it's i
think the only thing you can get is i i
made this little drawing a couple years
ago of the uh
illuminati pyramid with these it's the
um
the slogan for the us office's office of
censorship
toppled over and it was just like a
little piece of art i made and i was
like oh i'll slap it on something but i
do think we have a mug that's about to
come out and it's an ian mug
and it's the drake meme of ian and
there's an alligator underwater and
ian's like no
and then there's an alligator on land
and he's like yes yes because an
alligator underwater
because we were talking and we were
talking about getting dragged on twitter
and then
ian said yeah don't fight an alligator
underwater
you want to don't don't play their game
don't get in the mud
that's true that's a good that's a good
point but ian was i was like these
people on twitter you'll be you'll be
talking about a serious idea and then
also they'll change the subject and try
to insult you
yeah and then ian just goes yeah you
don't want to find an alligator
underwater yeah
i was like that's an excellent analogy
so we're going to have a mug of
you know you can drink fresh coffee out
of that that's right that's really
strong but we might we'll see we'll see
that's the old that's the old advice
about don't wrestle a skunk because
even if you win you're gonna yeah you're
not gonna smell great yeah
sock puppet joe says can you guys get
coleman hughes on the show
oh maybe if coleman wants to come on the
show i've actually interviewed coleman
who's in the past
so perhaps brandon says michael i've
been listening to your show since it
first aired back when i wasn't sure
where i stood politically
thanks for helping inspire the
patriotism and values in me to join
the usaf best decision i ever made man
that's awesome cool well thank you for
your service that
i was afraid i was going to say you know
i've tried to figure it out by listening
to your show and now i joined antifa so
thank you michael for you i realized i
hate you
uh twx rated says tim is controlled
opposition
well i am certainly not controlled
opposition
but i am fully self-aware of the issue
of the shift in the overton window and
why youtube likes the idea that they
have a channel like mine
yeah i think that i keep saying the ccp
i don't know i don't know but i think
they have like
sock puppets that comment that try to
sway your mind as a youtuber or
public opinion so that you without even
realize it start to repeat talking
points
so maybe maybe we're all being i also
know there is a recording device under
the beanie
i do know for a fact tim is a fed i know
on the back of my head is a little dish
yeah you never see his back on on film
yeah no one's ever seen it no it's true
that's true uh thomas cutler says
michael knowles ben shapiro let you out
yeah your stuff is awesome keep up the
good work thanks man i appreciate i know
i have to sneak out
although it's it's much easier these
days you know ben is spending more time
in florida and the land of the free and
now i get to be in
in nashville which i guess is also kind
of the land of the free out there
uh we're all we're all in a way better
mood ever since we got out of new
cellini's uh
hellhole oh nice yeah
michael brogan says holy s it's michael
effing knowles that's it that's the
super chat plug
speechless controlling words controlling
minds ping ping
ping plug counter that was that's my
favorite comment not only from this show
from weeks from weeks of my show too
what you have done with your show
and your audience to plug this book is
genius because now you come on my show
and they're making me promote your book
man that is
why do we have a marketing department at
the daily wire i don't
i want to start getting their salary too
i'm going to just remember your
marketing by having people
really though really the viewers should
be getting the salary they're doing all
the marketing yeah
that'd be incredible then they can have
more super chats it's a nice thing and
then i can say hey hey yeah
abby long says michael now that tim has
sponsors i'm sure he'd like to learn
from the best how to seamlessly
transition
yours are like sneaky ninjas wow that is
really
nice you know what one thing you you
need to do is you need to practice and
you need
to study but no one has any time so one
one great way to study is through the
great courses plus which you can
actually get right now with promo code
knowles getting wlas
am i i really did it i hope that
they give me credit for an extra plug
you know they do it by the read so i'm
going to talk to the department
yeah see what you can do it's good there
you go that's how it's done
s what is this sklizbot that's awesome
michael if you had one cigar to smoke
before your time comes what would it be
be a partagas 2008 15 anniversario
la casa del habano special release
that's what it would be
are those available for purchase in the
united states they are not they're not
available for purchase
any not only are they contraband they
are not available anywhere
rolled on the thighs of virgins yes
majestic great cigar joey martinez says
ian i am sorry for being hard on you
it's not your fault you have white
privilege
and can't pick up what tim lays down
dude i had to leave
one of my friends in la told me we were
in an argument about like hillary
clinton and like her
the email scanner and everything yeah
like you have you're you're you have
white privilege and i didn't know how to
how to respond it was like i felt
betrayed by my friend
i gave up on the la so you because you
knew a bunch of facts
you that's why so you're so the white
privilege is like
knowing things that seems very bigoted
it was so weird i could not defend
it it was the weirdest thing to be told
that i white privileged by someone yeah
i didn't do i don't know if i could i'm
kind of swarthy
i don't know if i do i count i don't
know it's the italian question
yeah it's plagued racialists for decades
all right bottled water says won't lie
and my fans know i struggle with
addiction
my mom died last year and my channel is
my escape i see my falls
i know my failures but i try admirable
right man i'm
sorry to hear that about your mind it's
a very very difficult uh thing to go
through
it uh i'm trying to think you know my
mother also died when i was young and uh
i was i was like an atheist at the time
i didn't have any addictions or anything
like that but
but it you know yeah i didn't have like
a really coherent moral framework and
it's a that's a very
difficult thing so i hope in some way
you know i do hope that
in you can come to not
you know not just a wishful thinking or
wish casting as you arrive at a moral
framework or some understanding of the
world
c.s lewis has a good line about this he
says that if you look for truth you
might find
comfort in the end but if you look for
comfort you'll find neither truth
nor comfort only soft soap and wishful
thinking to begin and in the end despair
so i think if you if you look for truth
hopefully you'll get a bit of comfort
out of that
right on advice bubbles ftw says knowles
you're awesome
loved another kingdom thanks to you and
drew for that
can you recount your argument to the
walnut brains who think a regulated
militia means the state should regulate
oh that's a good man i thought we were
going down in another kingdom
question and then we get to yeah well uh
yeah
the well-regulated militia would
obviously have to
be an antecedent to the state right
because if you've got this
well-regulated militia where where the
where's the militia getting the
arms from where is the militia getting
its organization from
especially in the case of the
revolutionary era so
you're saying we should embrace the
left's argument on the well-regulated
militia because it means the government
has to give everyone guns
yes i like like switzerland actually
yeah that's wow man i'm
thank you for the question thank you for
the point i'm going to take this
argument way further
we need we need such regulations that i
want like
two m-60s delivered to my door every
year
i'm i'm not kidding when i say universal
healthcare
okay well universal guns as well yeah so
we'll need that we'll need a department
of gun services
regulated by the government where you
can walk in and as soon as you're 16
they've got uh your choice of a handgun
and long gun yes and you get one of each
as well as a boxing ammo for both now
i do think there should be a very simple
test like with driving test yeah but
not um not an identification system
you know like obviously got to go with
your id or whatever to prove who you are
so you can
get the gun well that's but that would
be racist
how could but then that would be that
would be gun suppression in the
specifically in the black community
you're right you can't have it okay you
should be able to walk in and say one
gun please
there it is convinced me you think i'm
joking i used to be
kind of like middle of the road on 2a i
was like no i understand why we have it
but i think you know i've
seen some arguments about common sense
gun reform and then i had some real
conversations
and i was like okay yeah i was
definitely wrong about that so long as
second amendment exists it must be
respected in all its forms
then the riots happened and i was like i
would like 150 bmg please yes
can you get a couple of those bullpup
shotguns and uh how many guns can i
legally buy right now
all of them i'll take them all i noticed
it too you know when i was single i was
like
cool with guns but i didn't i don't
really care that much then i got married
i thought okay yeah i'd like to have a
gun just you know
in case my wife gets out of line or
something no no no i'm sorry yeah yeah
i'm sorry did you say a gun yeah well
this was the issue
because i you know i was just testing
the waters i said i want to be able to
protect my family but you know it's just
me and my wife whatever
we're living in an apartment then i have
the kid
and we moved to a house because we moved
to tennessee and now
i'm just like hey here is the wallet
i want all the guns you need a good
couple hundred yes at least just to be
you know just no no i think i'm
obviously joking about
but i love how like these it's not
leftists leftists love guns
they quote marx all the time about it
it's these like urban
uppity liberals who are very anti-gun
yeah and they all gloat to each other
about gun nuts and i'm like dude i don't
take guns that seriously have a bunch
because it's like a metal tube yeah it's
not it's not going to jump up and attack
you by the way
it's also well they refer to the you
know the gun nuts and all these crazy
people
and then they say things like you know
yeah he had a
200 round clip in his fully semi-auto
you know and they just have no idea what
they're talking about you know but where
they're nuts
do you think that teaching kids or like
16 year olds how to
how to build a gun maybe 3d print parts
and construct a gun and then fire it and
learn how to fire it would
would make them be more likely to commit
criminal acts with a gun
no no no then i think we should put it
in like shop class absolutely
totally 100 that's a good idea yeah
there are people walking around every
day with guns and you don't know it yeah
the amazing thing to me is that people
the reason like states like new jersey
and maryland only allow concealed carry
is because i guess people would freak
out or something but what that means is
when you're in a state as restrictive as
new jersey
there are people all around you all the
time carrying guns and you don't know it
yeah
and it's i mean you've not been shot the
key isn't i don't i don't like i
wouldn't make it the number one priority
to teach the kids how to
how to like 3d print a gun because i
want them to have a higher quality gun
too
but the real key is i need them to know
how to use a gun
just to be safe just to be safe around
my guns and just to be safe around
other people i was watching jack reacher
the other day and he walks up to a car
he hits the guy he takes his gun and
then he just goes click click click and
disassembles it and throws it and i'm
like see a kid should be able to do that
yes she'll be able to press
you know pull the hammer or whatever off
and just i felt phenomenally more
confident
after i fired gun i've only been to the
range once but luke was showing me
lukowski how to like
arm how to load a gun where the safety
is how you trigger how
do you arm it and it i feel just like so
much more confident as a human
knowing that well you know what homer
simpson says about this he says that
when you hold a gun
you feel like how god must feel when he
holds a gun
yeah well it reminds me of uh uh have
you the futurama episode you watch
you receive drama yeah yeah so it's the
one where it's the what if machine
and lila goes to like basically the
wizard of oz world
then they go and meet the professor and
uh
fry you know walks up and then he's like
for you a brain and then he's like why
do people keep saying this
but then uh zoidberg is the cowardly
lion and he's like i want courage and he
goes
oh who needs courage when you have a gun
and then he gives him a gun
and then zoey was like
who needs courage well that i think
that's how
joe biden and many people on the left
want you to
warn off the that's right the bad guys
you just just shoot it in the air like a
mexican gangster
yes no she was like why did the cop you
shoot the gun in the air because
the bullet would come down and kill
somebody have you ever heard of gravity
gravity
they think the bullet goes to outer
space yeah that light just keeps going
yeah i mean if if it was that simple to
launch things out of space i tell you
yeah all right christopher knowles says
michael you and i share a name via my
deadbeat grandfather coincidence
jk nothing but love don't ever stop what
you do you're doing the lord's work
lord's work graphene for the win wow
that is great i actually
can't from the writing of that question
i can't tell if
that was just a coincidentally a
christopher knowles or if that is my
actual cousin christopher
i'm going to say it's the latter and
here's why my cousin cree's a legendary
sort of guy
very very this is a guy who knows his
way around a firearm
and i hadn't seen him for a while you
know and that one time i'm waiting to
give a speech
and i walked in i was walking to u-pen
and he just like comes out from behind a
pillar somewhere he's like hey
hey what's up hey i was like man i can't
where did you come i haven't seen you in
a
while
he's like don't worry i'll just be in
the back just want to see the speech see
you later he's very so i bet it's him
he's always kind of around he is a very
impressive guy
iron price says when's the next time
luke will be on
luke abandoned us he did he left it is
unknown
man's motives are his own that's yeah do
you know luke
caskey i know i don't yeah he uh he's a
guy he runs we are change and he's got
his own website and youtube and stuff
and
he was here for a little while everybody
really loved him and then he left us
then he's gone
he's gone on to better pastures he's in
florida yes
he's in florida um bo darvill says
that's not rachel maddow
well you know we we over promised
perhaps how do you know have you ever
seen us in the same room at the same
time
no just lower your voice and you can do
either show
dan says i just want michael to know
that had a really intense experience
with edibles and watching compilations
of him owning libs helped me through it
also his hair looks great that's that's
an amazing super chat
it's like someone sitting there eating
edibles like this is getting crazy i
better watch michael knowles
oh he's on the lips yeah i i have
nothing to add to that i'm
just really pleased you ever load up
like a bunch of videos of you talking at
the same time and listen to them all at
once oh yeah well i only i only watch
myself when in my free time
yeah only right of course yeah it'll
change your life
yeah yeah i like to to after i record i
hit myself in the head so i forgot
everything i said
and then watch it like it's new yes
you've got to do it oh what's eight of
your videos
my stuff you can watch it on repeat
though it never gets old it's really oh
it's just great yeah my wife loves it
i don't play it the raptor's talent says
pride
the virtue is about understanding that
humans while capable of greatness
are only capable of so much pride the
sin
is the exaltation of self the belief
that you and only you are capable of
greatness
that's a good way to put it there's
something to that inordinate love of
one's own excellency
all right i'm gonna read it
joseph hoffman says michael i'm looking
forward to your new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
i'll make it worth it for michael coming
on the show right yeah we've
man i i'm probably like number one right
now on amazon i'll check after the show
i'll check out the show
all right we'll do a couple more we're
going a little over we have a ton of
super chats i really appreciate you guys
i wish i could read every everyone but i
can't so we'll do
we'll just do two more charlie in charge
says this is for everyone
what are your thoughts on changing your
legal status to a secured party creditor
sovereign citizen state nationalist pros
cons are those things
are those real or sovereign citizens is
that like you're declaring your
emancipation
from your country or something i don't
know if that's what it means
i'm against it i love my country even
though my country is driving me crazy
love of country is an extension of your
love of your parents and
you might maybe you got good parents
maybe you have bad parents but your
parents are your parents your kids or
your kids
and i could i could no more disavow my
country than i could disavow my own
family
this is the best country on the planet
yeah i'm open to the um the conversation
and the
like the logistics of that kind of thing
but i'm also kind of like i like this
the defensive structure of the united
states i mean the legal structure for
all its problems right now is still
just like the work of art i suppose the
present system in norway is better
yeah it's basically a hotel and all
right but they're also like what eight
million people or something
yeah 330 million people we got things we
got to fix man i'm all for prison reform
but
i think this is still the best country
on the planet yeah is there's pros and
there's cons for everything but
i know no interest in going any other
country at all right now covet
especially
but i don't have no interest i love this
country this is the thing even when you
go to countries that you like
i like italy i look italian part of my
family comes from italy
most beautiful art in the world good
food all right
but i go to italy i've gone a handful of
times
and after i don't know like five or six
days you just think i'll give an example
i was in siena
and this nice old medieval town and i go
to the sandwich shop
sandwich up is called a paninoteca pond
is the fur that means bread is the first
part of the word right
so i go it's like noon go to get a
sandwich
it's closed why i'm sitting there i have
a book i'm just okay i'll just read i'll
wait it probably is
okay 20 minutes goes by
30 minutes 45 minutes goes by the guy
fun he walks up
this is now past my lunch time and i say
oh good
can i buy a sandwich now he goes don't
chip on it
there's no bread i said there's no i
said well can i when can he goes i don't
know i'm going to go out and get the
bread
you can wait or you can go i said let me
i want to give you my money i want you
to give me a good and a service for
they don't get it america gets it much
more yeah all right this last one is a
very serious one
for you michael lex mccormick says
michael i struggle with the silence of
god
i debate a christian coworker often
about god's absence in my life
might might have you some insight for
someone who is jealous of those with
faith
why can't i hear the burning bush it is
an evil generation that looks for signs
and wonders
it is a stupid generation that ignores
signs and wonders and a lot of people
you know who are maybe going down the
wayward path this this happened to me
really and when i was you know in my
full wayward youth and atheistic phase
eventually after the intellectual parts
of it
of believing in god came through after i
was convinced about christianity
only then did i start to have these sort
of numinous experiences which you call
you call religious experience
and a lot of people feel really honored
by that and it isn't
you know in a way if you recognize this
sort of semiotic view of the world all
these
rich and symbols but also you could read
it as
god looking at you and saying hey buddy
hey you stupid idiot hey i'm right here
why can't you figure it out you know
and so if you're not if you're not
feeling the emotional
presence of god all the time you know
okay
i'm sorry for you if you know if you
really need that for your faith
god's existence is out is is true
and permanent outside of the emotional
feelings that you have and it's not
always going to be there and it won't
always be away either
i think i told this it's i guess it's
sort of a joke yesterday
about the the guy in the flood but
considering what this question just was
maybe a lot of people who haven't heard
it so i'm going to say it again and
we'll
we'll wrap up on this but let me just
tell you it's a joke story i guess
there's a man in his home and the news
comes on that there's
you know a horrible storm coming and he
prays and says you know my faith in god
will keep me safe and then all of a
sudden you know a car pulls up they run
to the door they bang on the door quick
we got to get out of here the water is
rising it's going to start flooding
you've got to come with us
and he says no no my faith in the lord
will will keep me safe
and they say no no don't be crazy he
refuses they leave
the water rises he goes up to a second
floor he starts praying again
then a boat comes to the window and the
guy says quick get in the boat we're
getting out of here we're going to save
you and he goes no no
i know that my faith in the lord will
save me and they're like you have to
come and he's like i i believe
in the lord finally they leave the
waters rise he climbs on his roof
now he's praying and a helicopter comes
and a guy's hanging from a ladder and he
says quick
climb up we're gonna save you and he
goes no i know that my faith in the lord
will save me
and they're like don't be crazy you have
to get in the helicopter and he refuses
the waters rise and he drowns he ends up
in heaven
and he goes he sees god and he goes and
he says i don't understand
i had faith in you why did you save me
and he said i sent a car a boat and a
helicopter and you wouldn't take it what
am i supposed to do
and i always thought that was a great
great joke that people expect um
too much of miracles i think they expect
too much of signs
and it's an interesting question about
what you know to me what faith is
because i'm not theistic by any stretch
of the imagination yeah no church for me
no bible and stuff
but i will say this i have seen some
stuff in my life
it's undeniable when you see it
sometimes and
you know someone told me something when
i was younger you can't give someone an
experience
yeah and so you know i was hanging out
with these uh these these
these skater dudes that i knew they were
very christian and we're having
philosophical conversations it was
amazing stuff
and they just said i'm not interested in
trying to justify
my my beliefs to you because like i'll
explain to you how i feel
i'll tell you what i think is true and
because i want to help you but i
understand i can't give you the
experience i had
and i'm like i totally understand that
yeah i can i can
empathize and then in my life i've just
seen things that to me have been
profound
and indicative of something greater this
is profound i mean just the fact that
two salt water monkey bodies are sitting
here
verbally making communication and i'm
like this is god talking to me through
you
through the your vibration in your these
magical brain things
that's the thing right you know when you
talk about like magnetism and stuff it's
it's easily just the mechanism of
mechanisms of god and that i think
there's a lot of people who have either
a reductionist view or a very simplistic
view and they'll say something like
no that's not a miracle that's just the
vibrations and it's like
the mechanisms of god of all the things
i've been called on this show tonight
salt water monkey body it's my favorite
one that is
very vivid i heard you have a book
coming out
yeah only through the super chat we'll
lead through the super all right
everybody
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel if you like the show share with
your friends and go to timcast.com right
in the top right corner there's a little
bunch as members only you can click that
sign
up and then in the members area you'll
see we are going to have an exclusive
members only section we're going to go
we're going to talk about god and faith
a little bit more and
ian and magnetism and we'll we'll have
some crazy profound
you know conversations so to check that
out you can follow me on all social
media platforms at tim cast
this show is live monday through friday
at 8 p.m so we will be back monday after
this
you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcastnews
michael knowles is there something you
want to promote while you're well i
don't know
i mean i got a few things going on i do
have this book though
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it's available now for pre-order
we'll see how much longer this thing
what is it about by the way well you
know this and that it's a lot about what
we're talking about i actually i can
give you a sort of brief description of
it
it's a history of political correctness
from 1920 to 2020
it is uh following the leftist
intellectuals who brought us along
i learned writing the book that the
leftist intellectuals who created this
thing called pc or locism
know a lot more about free speech than
we do and that we give them credit for
it breaks down why every step of the way
we lost
in in my humble opinion and it does
briefly
sketch a way i think that we can move
forward which is to ditch this silly
abstract talk about
free speech absolutism academic freedom
whatever
and start talking about a real
substantive
moral visions that necessarily will
include certain ideas and exclude other
ideas we need to
take what the left is doing which is
immoral and unjust and wrong
and we need to do the just right good
version of that because they wield
political power much better than we do
we'd love to have you back when it comes
out
thank you and promote it and hold it up
and we can talk about all those ideas
it'd be great it'd be great thank you
right on
you also you have twitter and and yes
that's true i was so focused on plugging
the book
i do though you can find me on twitter
for now at michael j knowles i
i do have my daily show at the daily
wire which is the michael knowles show
i also do a show at prageru called the
book club i also do a show with senator
ted cruz called verdict which is super
fun
and schedules are a little tough right
now but we're hopefully going to get
some new episodes out
really really soon and but you can catch
you can catch all that basically at the
daily but that's like one of the biggest
podcasts in the world i think
yeah yeah no it's so i i never thought
you know
especially for that first couple weeks i
love senator cruz
i really really like and admire the guy
i'm just saying
i never thought he could hit number one
podcaster there's a lot of good
podcasters out there you know
and but i really love doing the show i
think he's bringing
so much of behind the curtains of what's
really going on there so
uh we got more episodes of that show
coming up too you can always follow me
iancrossland.net and at ian crossland on
all social media
michael this is great thank you guys
first hour and a half just flew by
looking forward to talking more and i'm
sour patch list in the corner i push
buttons that's my job you can follow me
at sourpatchlids on twitter
join me in my quest to have more
followers than sour patch kids
we're gonna go over to timcast.com which
should be up in maybe an hour so but i
have a feeling this conversation might
go a little long
it's friday night and it's a really fun
conversation these are the conversations
i love more than anything else is like
the deeper questions so
timcast.com and we'll see you all there
bye guys
you